e
e e
okay good morning everybody Welcome to
transportation
uh before we get started on our public
hearings if I can
have rise for the Pledge of Allegiance
please thank you for that uh and I'll
just announce now I am I still have the
residuals from an illness I will do my
best at these hearings if you see me
suddenly get up and run out of the room
uh it's probably so I don't want to
disrupt these hearings so we're going to
give it a shot uh I'm going to open up
the public hearing
on House Bill 119 FN which is allowing
rental companies applying to register a
rental Fleet to choose New Hampshire as
their base jurisdiction under the
international registration plan I do not
see the prime sponsor here here so as a
courtesy can I get somebody just to go
up front and introduce the bill
officially obviously you don't have to
chime in on
opinions sure thank you
sir thank you Mr chair honorable
committee uh for record representative
Henry G
Hillsboro 29th District here to
introduce House Bill 119 allowing rental
companies to apply to register a rental
Fleet and to choose New Hampshire as the
base jurisdiction under the
international registration plan
IRP thank you very much represent
geen uh chair recognizes
Liz mow representing the Department of
Motor Vehicles IRP
registrations uh not taking a position
on the
bill come on up good
morning hello all right good morning um
I had just reviewed this um recently
oops I can stop you just to make it
official if you can just state your name
I mean I did but you're supposed to do
it yourself Liz mad registration Bureau
at the
DMV um I also was looking at the fiscal
note that was prepared um I did want to
just add a few things um this bill um
that is being proposed allows for rental
companies applying to register a
passenger vehicle um as a fleet in New
Hampshire currently the international
registration program does allow for this
um it's on page 48 of our International
registration plan um so we already have
this
capability um and therefore um we would
not
need the um proposed additional Staffing
that's on the fiscal note because this
is something that we already
offer I'm happy to take any
questions questions from the committee
representative uh thank you Mr chairman
uh if we already offer it what does this
bill change to
enable I don't think
anything okay thank you you're welcome
any other questions from the
committee representative Hill thank you
Mr chairman and thank you for taking my
question um we have had conversations
about this I believe
um can
does does the legislation change
anything as far as um the locality of
where the
registrations are to be
done uh no according to the IRP plan
they can use New Hampshire as their
based jurisdiction if they so choose um
so it doesn't impact where a rental
company could set up their Fleet they
just have to meet the requirements of
the IRP plan which means they have a
business in New Hampshire um and they
store primarily their Fleet in New
Hampshire um all of the criteria that
goes with
it U oh sorry about that follow up quick
follow thank you
um what would be
necessary for um
implementation of this
um as envisioned by the prime sponsor if
he were here um that we don't already
have a policy or procedure to
accomplish so the option is available um
I think we would just need one of the
larger rental vehicle passenger vehicle
rental companies to reach out um we
would have to figure out how to um
assist them in tracking their their
mileage and making sure that they're
submitting the right uh funds to each
state another followup rep thank you um
how about the um the stickers um how
would they on
on on these rental fleets that um I've
I've heard anecdotally in the past that
it's very difficult where they would
have to track where those vehicles are
that had been registered here um so how
would that be envisioned or how is that
currently handled So currently every
year they would need to um re renew
their registrations and put those
stickers on the plates that coincide
with that car so they would need to find
that car somewhere so it could be out in
Colorado um but it's registered in New
Hampshire they need to put the decal
sticker on that
car sure anybody else from the committee
I know good now anybody else from the
committee okay thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking my question um with
the IRP
document um does it get into specific
guidelines like the rest of this bill
does in terms of the calculation for the
number of
um um registrations or um specifying
that they must operate the rental
vehicle here um does it get that
specific no the IRP plan's more of
General guidelines um and then we
adopted it as rule so um it's kind of I
guess this would be an addition onto
that thank you Mr chair uh thank you for
taking my question so if rental car
companies can already register their
vehicles in New
Hampshire uh businesses cost conscious
always looking to save money does
registering their vehicles in New
Hampshire give them any type of a cost
Advantage as opposed to register them
where they do
now
um I don't see one um only because a
passenger vehicle
registration
um it's it's going to charge them the
same as if they an a portioned vehicle
registration the difference with the a
portion vehicle registration is we track
it in the system and then pay fuel tax
to all of the uh states that they
traveled into so um it makes it easier
for businesses that are doing business
in our state um to not have to get trip
tickets you can only get like three trip
tickets over a certain period of time um
so this just makes that easier but I'm
not sure about the rental cars what
the but again I don't know what the um
what the benefit would be for them I
just don't know
you anybody else from the committee
repres gki thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for taking my question is
there a certain amount of time that um a
vehicle has to be in New Hampshire if
it's registered by these rental
companies uh no they actually only need
like one mile in New Hampshire so long
as they get at least one mile in the
state that they're registered yes thank
you you're welcome anybody else I have
one uh because it just came to uh to to
to me a couple of days ago I don't know
if you know the answer to this are the
rental companies actually seeking States
for their whole fleets or do they prefer
to have a portion of their Fleet in
every state they actually do business in
because of the different
laws I don't know that one sorry anybody
else representative Hill um inspections
can you speak to inspections of these
rental fleets So currently the
inspections would be the same um as all
of the other vehicles in New Hampshire
annually um so they would still require
those inspections safety
inspections follow follow up
um what would what would it obviously
wouldn't mean that someone that has
their uh that vehicle then in Colorado
has to come running back um once a year
to do it what what happens in that
situation with where the vehicle is out
of state I believe to drive in New
Hampshire they would have to have that
New Hampshire state inspection
okay thank
you what if they're not driving into
hampire then they probably would not
have an IRP
account not us as a base jurisdiction I
should clarify that yeah anybody else
any other questions from the committee
seeing none thank you very much thank
you next up chair recognizes Bob Skully
representing the H motor transport
Association no position on the bill good
morning Mr scy morning Mr chairman
members of the committee it's a pleasure
to be here today to speak on House Bill
119 FN um like the previous speaker said
um we're not taking a position but we
don't feel this bill is needed you can
already do what this bill's looking to
do in New Hampshire but I do want to
speak a little bit to the truck side so
if you go down to on
page one down on line 26 when it refers
to a rental company that owns trucks
registered 26,000 or less so that's a
commercial motor vehicle by definition
if it's over 10,000 10,000 one and up we
have
RP so a trucking company if they have a
physical exposure in any state multiple
States they can choose which state to
register that vehicle so um did a
question representative Hamlin excuse me
asked there's a disadvantage for
truckers to register in the state of New
Hampshire if they have other states and
that's because of the property tax that
you have so I will give an example um
very large rental Fleet registered all
their equipment in the city of
Manchester a long time ago I went down
with the representative to try to see if
there's something we could do to help
them out with the cost because it was
excessive um there was no ability to do
that and moved all the equipment for all
of New England to Kingsboro
Massachusetts and so the city of
Manchester lost all the revenue um I
understand that municipalities is their
second largest source of income there's
been multiple attempts to try to change
that since I've been here none initiated
by me they've all failed miserably um
once the local communities get involved
up here but that is why on the truck
side anyways if they have an option you
know it's cheaper for them to register
them in Indiana and they have a physical
base there they could register I just
picked that state randomly they could
register all their equipment there um if
they have a physical being there um if
New Hampshire is the only place that
they're based physically then that's
where they have to register their
equipment if it's a truck but that would
be I did not speak to the prime sponsor
but I would think maybe that was some of
the motive to try to generate Revenue
but I don't know that for sure but I
just wanted to share that with you on
the truck side um uh but there's nothing
in this bill here that you can't
currently do today from our
perspective thank you much any questions
from the committee seeing none thank you
thank you Mr chairman I have nobody else
signed up to speak on host Bill
119 FN so I'm going to
close so I'm going to close a public
hearing I have no other people signed up
to
speak um our next hearing 10:20 give us
a few minutes to reset please it'll be
House Bill
e
e e
okay welcome back we're going to open up
the public hearing on House Bill 612 FN
enabling the Division of Motor Vehicles
to create a temporary traditional
driver's license for youth operators
about to turn 21 chair recognized the
prime sponsor representative beay good
morning good morning Mr chairman and
members of the House Transportation
committee for the record my name is Dan
veu I represent Hillsboro 34 the town of
Amherst um thank you for the opportunity
to present uh House Bill 612 this bill
addresses an important but often
overlooked issue for youth operators
transitioning to adult licenses it
offers a practical solution and saves
time and reduces unnecessary hassle for
both drivers and
DMP under current law youth operators
face unnecessary challenges When
approaching the 21st birthday
particularly if their birthday falls in
a weekend holiday or if they prefer to
renew online
uh the process is that if their birthday
falls in a weekday it's not a problem
they can visit the DMV on that day and
receive the standard horizontal license
however if their birthday falls on a
weekend or a holiday they must renew
before their birthday in which case they
will receive a vertical youth operator's
license many drivers who don't want to
have a youth operator's license for
another five years must then return to
the DMP after their birthday to obtain
the horizontal license which will then
be marked as a
duplicate for those who wait until after
their birthday their license becomes
technically
invalid this can be particularly
challenging for those who are away at
school as ret turning home at the right
time may not be feasible these drivers
are left without the ability to drive or
are forced to risk driving on an expired
license youth operators who wish to
renew online and receive a horizontal
license must also wait until their 21st
birthday to do so if they renew even one
day early they receive a vertical
license and face the same inconvenience
of returning to the DMV later
additionally renewing online involves a
waiting period while the license is
printed and mailed leaving drivers
without any legal proof of renewal
during that
time this inefficient process wastes
time for drivers and increases the
workload for the
DMV HB 612 provides a simple and
practical solution that allows youth
operators to submit their renewal
application up to 30 days before their
21st birthday and receive a temporary
license valid for driving
purposes this temporary license ensures
they can transition seamlessly to the
standard horizontal license on or
shortly after their birthday regardless
of whether the birthday falls in a
weekend
holiday um why this matters first it
eliminates unnecessary trips DMV drivers
can submit their application once and
receive the license they prefer saving
time and
frustration it reduces the burden on DMV
staff by cutting down the duplicate
license requests making operations more
efficient it's cost it's a cost-
effective solution a one-time system
update costing 48,000 will streamline
the process for years to come this bills
brings flexibility and modernization to
New Hampshire's licensing process it
reflects the realities of how people use
and prefer their licenses while aligning
the system with the needs of today's
drivers I urge the committee to support
HB 612 and I'd be happy to answer any
questions thank you for your
time thank you so much any questions
from the
committee representative
gon I I do have one question uh thank
you
representative this might be better for
the director of the DMV but um is this
an easier process than extending the
expiration date 30 days after the 21st
birthday yeah it
it might be better for the director but
um yeah
it it it spreads out the workload on the
DMV um it makes it easier right now
yeah I would defer to the DMD on that
one they probably have a better answer
than I
would any other questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you
sir chair now would like to recognize uh
director morasco from the New Hampshire
DMV who is in support of the bill asking
for about three minutes uh welcome
director morning Mr chair members of the
committee thank you so much for the
opportunity speak this morning uh as you
said Mr chair uh we at the DMV 100%
support this bill I want to thank
representative V uh for at the end of
the last session um highlighting this
and and bringing it to my attention that
he'd like to Champion this change I can
tell you that in my three years in the
position as the MV director I have had
more parents young people in the
community come up to me and say um why
do I receive the vertical license in the
mail uh after I've turned 21 I thought I
was doing everything right because the
renewal notice goes out and it lets
people know we encourage you to renew
early well if you renew early online um
what people didn't know and it's because
of the way the system was configured uh
they're renewing a youth operator and so
when they would get their license in the
mail it would be the vertical youth
operator license again this has been
going on for 15 years they would have to
come into the DMV and then pay $10 for a
duplicate um and take an updated photo
and then receive their horizontal
license that they're entitled to because
they turned 21 um so I love this bill
because this bill gives an opportunity
for uh that 30 days in advance um to
representative A's point it spreads out
the volume 30 days in advance you can go
online you can renew your driver's
license you can get the receipt that you
renewed you can use your currently uh
valid youth operator license that if you
had to show both you could and then
we're going to do the
$48,000 system change so that when you
ear 21 in the system that's it's going
to trigger us to mail you the horizontal
license that shows that you're over 21
and while that's in transit you still
have your youth operator license for the
30 days past that date with the receipt
until you get your hard copy in the mail
and uh currently we're delivering
licenses we're printing licenses same
day or next day uh generally speaking so
we're confident we'll we'll be able to
fulfill that 30-day window but um this
is a uh this is a big issue and you hear
it from a lot of people in the community
to include if you want to go into the
DMV like the representative said and
it's a weekend or it's a holiday and
that happens to be your 21st birthday
well we're not open um so where does
that leave you now you've got to go a
couple days without driving until you
can get somebody to drive you to the DMV
so that you can actually apply to get
your horizontal license so I think it's
a it's a great fix and I want to thank
representative a for um bringing it
forward and uh getting us to this point
I'm happy happy to take any
questions thank you sir any questions
from the committee representative Miller
thank you Mr chairman thank you uh
director for your testimony I just want
to confirm the logistics of these the
new licenses being printed the
horizontal ones yall will hold them or
not print them until the appropriate
time that's not going to be a logistical
problem with the flow of licenses coming
out of the office that will weird
anything out along the way right no it's
a great representative Mill great
question and one that we definitely want
to make sure we got just right and
speaking with our technology vendors you
can write uh once once the renewal takes
place um they can write a program so
that um that is being tracked and as
soon as at midnight when the 21st
birthday uh takes place that's when the
uh it would go into the queue to be
printed in hard copy so um we would we
would cover that but that's a great
question thank
you representative
Peto thank you Mr chair and thanks for
taking my question
um I just wanted to clarify the the idea
of it seemed like a lot of the languages
in here was about a temporary license
but it sounded like the scenario you're
describing is essentially
granting um a 30-day extension to the
youth license in
practicality am I correct or can you
just narrow in on that yeah that that's
a great question so the the youth
operator uh for purposes of still being
valid would go beyond um the 21st
birthday so that you're still operating
on a license that that you renewed but
quite frankly once that once that hard
copy is printed and you're waiting for
it um for purposes of driving you're
valid and you are actually in the eyes
of law enforcement because you're over
21 you've got the youth operator um
receipt or the youth operator license
that you got at the DMV because that's
all we were able to give you at those
two moments in time but for purposes of
law enforcement you're going to be
considered a non- youth operator until
you get your hard copy in the mail so
that's that's a good point um but that's
that's all we can offer you at that
moment in time when you come in and
renew is that youth operator
again any other questions from the
committee representative G
gon thank you Mr chair um Vice chair yes
Mr
D Mr director um so similarly to what I
ask the representative is this program
going to be easier than trying to create
a shift of dates so that nobody's
expiring on their 21st
birthday yeah it's a good question I we
used the Whiteboard we talked about a
lot of different um we looked at this
this option as the optimal option um I'd
have to play that out a little bit um so
basically what you're saying is we just
give the youth operator the extra 30
days we give it the extra 30 days um but
then you still have to you still have to
have the renewal that would have to take
place or the inperson visit
it prior to the 21st to trigger
something in the system to allow you to
get something that's going to be mailed
out to you so I you're still going to
have to have that work on the front end
to trigger what's going to happen on the
back end so I don't know if just the
extension will be enough follow up so in
in your opinion this is the best way to
move forward correct yes thank you thank
you representative representative
Sykes yeah thank you uh Mr chair
director morasco can you if this is a an
expired um and their out of state how
how is this going to work if the if the
license has expired and they're out of
state yeah that's a great question
representative thank you for that well
the license receipt so if you renew
online you have that license receipt and
then you've got the youth operator
license hard copy that you've had for
the four almost five years um you'd be
showing both of those um in the system
so in the system if you were to run that
you're going to see because of this bill
that you're still going to be valid as
an operator in the state of New
Hampshire uh for law enforcement to see
the 30 days after your 21st
birthday any other questions from the
committee is that a followup George yeah
followup um so how would it work as a
grace period in other words getting back
to that
concept the on the on the back side so
the uh the youth operator status the
driver license status is still good for
the 30 days after the 21st birthday um
so anybody that checks the system you're
going to be you're going to have your
active status as far as the hard copy
license in transit um obviously you
won't have that to show during that
30-day window but um but you still have
a valid identification a valid license
that you can present if you have an
interaction with law
enforcement thank you any other
questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you sir
thank you everyone and uh we do not have
any other pin cards so at this point I'm
going to close the hearing on HB
612 our next bill we'll be hearing
shortly is HB
e
e e
okay welcome back everybody I want to
try this one more time going to open up
the public hearing on uh House Bill 209
FN allowing a new vehicle purchased in
the model year or before to be inspected
in the second year after purchase uh
Prime sponsor couldn't make it on time
for this introduction so representative
St
Clair welcome thank you I'm uh Charlie
stclair District 5
lonia and I truly wish the prime sponsor
was here because I know he would do a
better job than I'm probably going to
this bill um as some of you remember was
before us last year and probably several
times before that this would allow new
vehicles purchased to basically after
their first inspection wait another year
after to get an inspection sticker so
basically what we're we're saying
I believe is that you go two years on
the same sticker
um on a on a note that most of us we're
going to hear all kinds of reasons why
they shouldn't happen but I want to
remind everybody that with a new vehicle
the owners are trained to look at the
warranty
requirements and you reach a certain
mileage and you're going to go back in
and get War the checks for the warranty
otherwise your warranty is null and void
and
nobody wants
that you're going to go in for oil
changes quite often uh these places will
offer free oil
changes your car goes in for that oil
change they're going to check everything
else actually do that for the rest of
your life they're going to try to
upcharge on everything and and that's
pretty much uh the way it goes
everywhere so I think um on behalf of
the taxpayers who this is going to help
out uh this is a good Bill and certainly
my constituents when I bring this up to
them people that have bought a new
vehicle say yeah that makes sense that
that's that's great great do
it that's pretty much going to be my
introduction to this
bill all right thank you representative
any questions from the committee
representative Hamlin thank you Mr
chairperson thank you for taking my
question does this apply to commercial
vehicles as well
that's a good question but I do I did
not see that in
here uh I don't think it does I don't I
don't believe it does because we had
that discussion before about commercial
vehicles so I do not believe that do
this is for private uh Vehicles not
commercial right we'll confirm but I
believe that to be true I don't believe
it does uh any other questions from the
committee seeing none they let you off
the hook pretty easy representative say
that again they let you off the hook
pretty easy easy they did thank you uh
next up chair
recognizes Daniel weed represent the
industry opposed to the
bill ladies and gentlemen good morning
appreciate the time this morning uh
sorry to see that the prime sponsor is
not here this morning because uh some of
these questions are directed towards him
and his career I see by the state
legislator's website that he is a
professional pilot uh and it's
surprising to me that of all the people
as a career pilot that he would ask to
resend an inspection program he clearly
understands the importance of an annual
inspection program regarding aircraft uh
so why wouldn't a series of vehicles
that has 50 times the amount of volume
on the road uh require an inspection you
can't fly an aircraft without an annual
inspection can you and would this as a
career pilot would he even fly an
aircraft without an annual inspection so
why should should your car be any
different uh the way this bill is
written uh it now exempts 2 years from
Cars light trucks medium trucks heavy
trucks RVs trailers and commercial
vehicles there's no exemption in this
bill to the way it's written so if you
can imagine an 880,000 lb
18-wheeler with its trailer and
everything uh Exempted for 2 years and
when these vehicles do at least 50 plus
thousand miles a year it's 100,000 miles
before that heavy commercial vehicle is
inspected uh based on numbers by motor
vehicles uh given to me this will now
eliminate
25,2 30h a year based on statistics
given by eliminating the two model years
he will now need to modify the contract
with the current inspection program
provider the contract will have to be
Rewritten to pass the cost on to those
of us who don't have new
vehicles you will then see the cost of
annual inspections increase from the
current market rate of approximately $40
to $50 potentially to $75 to
$100 and I don't see calculations for
the loss of income in the bill uh to the
small local businesses and if you take
that
205,000 230 inspections that you're
reducing by an average of say $50 per
inspection you're reducing the income to
small businesses per year by 10,000 10,
$276,500 to the state small businesses
so you're taking $10 million away from
small
businesses please keep in mind that the
people that you're going to most affect
are those that don't have the extra
money to begin with I can clearly
Envision tomorrow's
headlines inspection elimination Bill
proposed to help reduce government
oversight while doubling the cost of
inspections to the state's
residents thank you
thank you very much any questions from
the committee if you'll take any
represent
G thank you Mr chair thank you sir so
your position then is that uh because
the government mandates inspections the
less inspections that the government
mandates the higher the price would have
to be for the private
vendor that's correct correct
yes other
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank
you um the cards keep coming in uh um
just because I'm sure he has other
business to attend to late arrival
representative McFarland in support of
the bill welcome
sir thank you I appreciate you uh sling
me in there representative McFarland
from Orange uh here to testify in
support of this bill I I don't have a
lot to say I think the bill speaks for
itself I I do however want to convey
that uh my constituents are uh
interested Ed in Road Safety but they
are also interested in cost of living
and if you have a brand new vehicle uh
it is good for a period of time that
that is typically longer than some of
the older vehicles out there I support
this bill and if there's any questions
I'm happy to Y to
them thank you sir any questions from
the committee seeing none thank you
again thank
you uh next up chair
recognizes Allison
Brinson I guess it is representing new
car in opposed to the
bill and you've got five to 10 minutes
down I see a lot of people coming in so
if you can I promise I won't speak that
long it up that'd be great thank
you good morning everyone my name is
Alicia I'm the service manager of new
car automo in til to New Hampshire I
just wanted to go over some general
information in regards to state
inspections currently so the 13
inspectable items include registration
plates registration certificate and
vehicle identification number steering
and suspension brakes including parking
brake odometer and speedometer
electrical system horn and defroster
lights and reflectors including
headlight aim glass glazing mirrors
wipers exhaust system odd board
diagnostic systems body chassis bumper
height fuel system tires and wheels um
none of these components really show
Grace in regards to time and/ or mileage
I've seen it firsthand I've seen
vehicles with 12,000 Mi come in with
lower than 2 30 seconds of tread um I've
seen multiple Vehicles come in with
rusted or pitted rotors causing a
vehicle to fail inspection um doesn't
allow for Effective braking and once
again this does not show any Grace in
regards to mileage Andor time I've seen
it on new vehicles I've seen it on
10-year-old Vehicles doesn't really show
Grace unfortunately we drive on salted
roads so all of these components
typically are influenced very young in a
vehicle's lifetime even when you think
about it if you're not driving your
vehicle your vehicle's sitting it's
going to get rusted if you are driving
your vehicle I mean some people put
30,000 40,000 miles on their vehicle per
year all these components are wearable
items they're going to wear by time and
mileage and it's going to be well within
the threshold of one year Andor two
years of ownership um so I definitely
strongly appeal this and if anybody has
any questions please let me
know thank you very much for your
testimony any questions from the
committee uh representative Crawford
thank you Mr chair do you have any
written
testimony with all those facts on it I
do not okay thank
you any other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much uh next up chair recognizes Bob
Scully represented Hamp for motor
transport not taking a position on the
bill welcome back sir
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee um my name is Bob Scully
representing New Hampshire Motor
Transport Association I just want to
clarify inspections with commercial
Motor Vehicles because it's been talked
about twice here so any commercial motor
vehicle must be inspected once a year
it's under federal guidelines it very
specifically it's under 49 CFR Cod of
Federal Regulation 396 appendix a so at
once every 12 months they must be
inspected um so this legislation cannot
impact that so I just wanted to clarify
that thank you appreciate it sir thank
you uh next up chair recogniz is Dan
Bennett representing the Hampshire Auto
Dealers Association in opposition to the
bill seeking five minutes but I know he
can do it in much
less yes
sir uh thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee I will be uh as brief as
possible Dan Bennett New Hampshire Auto
Dealers Association as you know we're
tra Association representing the motor
vehicle industry over 500 businesses
15,000 uh employees in the state of New
Hampshire car truck motorcycle
snowmobile ATV construction and farm
equipment um again we're here to oppose
HB 209 as we have in the past years um
this bill is not about new cars a new
car is a car that rolls right off the
the the truck from Detroit or Deerborn
or wherever it comes from I I'm willing
to bet that if you went to purchase a
vehicle you rolled into that dealership
uh after 15 months and 25 ,000 miles on
the vehicle when you went to purchase it
you would not call that a new vehicle
okay so this when when we call this
about new vehicles this is not about new
vehicles it's about vehicles that can go
up to 24,000 excuse me 24 months um with
an incredible number of miles we employ
a fleet uh of of our road staff our
safety prevention loss prevention uh
they average 25,000 mil per year uh this
vehicle will in fact apply to um to
commercial vehicles it's uh it's right
there um and section uh four new
paragraph 4 a line 9 or line 8 and N
deal with corporations and the inspect
the months in which in corporate
Vehicles will be inspected um this also
isn't a two-year sticker bill this is an
exemption Bill uh so there there's
nothing in this bill affords a a new
vehicle to roll off the truck and get a
two-year sticker this is a no inspection
sticker for two years so um I anticipate
law enforcement both state and local
will have something to say about that um
so I'll try and bounce through my
testimony I do in fact have copies of
our handouts which has a lot of
information that I'll send both ways um
including a copy for the clerk um so a
couple uh points that I'll mention um as
of January 2025 Carfax um says that over
58.1 M million vehicles are on the road
um that have unresolved safety uh
recalls um it's a 16% increase in over
two years um the manufacturers are are
prioriti in ride quality over longevity
um and tires we're hearing show tread uh
tread failure uh at 20,000 Mi um and we
see a lot of incidences especially
recently where Vehicles slide off the
road um you know creating accident or
injury or unsafe um conditions and it's
usually due to Tire condition um so in
in the past we've talked about studies
we did a lot of research in the off year
um the most recent study we found a July
2023 Journal of Transportation engine in
article found that states without safety
inspections have 5% uh fewer annual
fatalities than those without this past
year as you all know probably seen from
TV radio WMUR um in 2024 135 people died
on New Hampshire roads which was a 5%
increase over last year but the really
scary fertility or really scary
statistic is that youth youth fatalities
Rose over
233% so we would venture to say this is
not a time to weaken the of New
Hampshire roads um and that's what we
believe this vehicle will do
um um I believe you'll probably hear
from the Department of Environmental
Services as we have historically as to
whether the EPA would even uh approve
this amendment to our state
implementation plan under our Clean Air
Act requirements uh which is tied to
Federal Highway funding
um there is talk about States and places
that weaken their program however what
we are in fact seeing and it's based on
that study from the Journal of
transportation engineering um that
several jurisdictions International
jurisdictions have already adapted
safety inspections to include testing
and calibrating systems that's some
of the more technical equipment that's
in your vehicle the Advanced Driver
assistance systems the lane steering the
lane correction the vibrating steering
wheel um you know the the lane change um
as well as the forward and and behind
Collision Repair so um what we're
actually seeing as a focus on that is is
actually a deeper dive into what items
should be inspected um all of our
neighboring states do safety inspections
it's because New England has a unique
microclimate you'll see it in the
handout that I have we include a winter
severity map that you all have seen
before you can talk about snowier States
um but New England's microclimate is
much more severe um we have we have rain
at first of the year we have deep
freezes we have Frost Hees we spray
liquid saltwater on our roads that then
splatters onto the undercarriage of our
vehicles and coats all of our equipment
inclusing including hoses brakes rotors
um so you'll see that in what we um in
what we hand out for you um from some of
the failure statistics that we have just
so you know you know in model year 2024
there's 1.3 million safety inspections
done um you know there were over 170,000
failures um and that's in that in in
that 2024 year so we still have
incredibly High failure numbers even
with um even with our safety inspection
program and an important component of
the safety inspection program is it does
a mandatory safety recall data check to
see if you have an outstanding safety
recall that recall is then done at the
consumer and it's done at the consumer
at no cost just like these vehicles in
their first two years which is usually
about a manufacturer's warranty there
are some outliers Honda or Hyundai may
go 10 years um but it catches items that
are under warranty that are done at no
cost to the consumer and that's why it
has a value to the consumer not a cost
same thing with recall data we miss a
lot of those little postcards that come
in our mailbox but you don't when you're
service riter tells you across the
counter or slams that seat on your
passenger seat and you see that there's
a a service recall related to your O2
sensor um in 2025 alone there's already
been 465 safety recalls issued in 2024
to New Hampshire consumers this is in
20124 there were over 10,000 safety
recalls issued to Consumers and in 2023
there were over 21,000 so all this is
put in front of the consumers this is a
consumer friendly program um we would
say um and then just the other item that
I'll mention to and I'll stop before the
chairman throws me out is the fiscal
impact um you'll see at the end of the
bill there is a fiscal note to the state
you all have heard about the the um the
budgetary issue that we're having um
this is no time to be lessening Monies
to um the state highway fund as well as
the monies from this program that go to
the local municipalities so um with that
being said um we'd like you to keep that
in mind um and please take a look at um
the information that that we send around
both ways um and I'll be willing to take
questions here or in person or after
digesting some of this offline but um
thank you Mr
chairman thank you sir questions from
the committee I believe I have one front
loaded representative Hill thank you Mr
chairman um and thank you for taking my
question M Bennett um are you saying
that the increase in motor vehicle
deaths are attributable to um
inspectable items no I'm not saying that
they it's attributable directly to
inspection items but what I'm saying is
that we have a a situation where our
roads are becoming more unsafe our
contention is that if you stop
inspecting Vehicles it will be more
unsafe vehicles on the road so we would
tend to say that would probably
contribute to that going forward I'm not
going to say that the 135 fatalities are
strictly mechanical
failures thank you just clarifying
any other questions from the committee
representative hlin thank you Mr
chairman uh thank you for taking my
questions so I just want to clarify in
my mind is it your position that brand
new vehicles ones that have never been
titled before when they leave the
dealership they do not have an
inspection sticker on them for two
years uh thank you for the question
representative hlin under this bill as
written our belief is that this provides
no mechanism for a 2-year sticker it's
it doesn't talk about anything about a
two-year sper when it actually says uh a
vehicle purchased during the prior to or
during the vehicle model year from a
licensed dealer by natural person shall
be exempt from inspection until the last
day of the register's owner birth month
in the second year after purchase
doesn't say that they'll get a two-year
sticker that expires on their birth date
it just says no expect it's an exemption
from the program completely for both
commercial and passenger
vehicles thank you that is an accurate
reading follow up follow up thank you um
so one more little track I know for a
fact that people have buy new vehicles
and within the first year they're in an
accident have to go to a body shop and
built rebuilt partially or
extensively um do you have any data or
is there anything that says when those
cards come back into u a shop that some
the mechanic will pick up on something
that was fosly done in the body shop
that now has to be Rec
corrected so
uh
the following the so let me see if I if
I follow your question and then try and
answer it accurately so following the
Collision when your vehicle is required
by your insurance policy to be restored
to pre-loss condition you would then
leave that instance and then you would
go for your annual inspection the annual
inspection would review items that are
under the annual inspection program it
would not do an analysis of whether the
cons the the restoration at The Body
Shop met the
manufacturers uh repair procedures or
the pre-loss condition agreement that
you had with your insurance agent it
would be based on what the state
inspection program is um as um Miss
Britain referred to so uh the inspection
station would would not be checking the
validity of the body shops repair
process if that's what you're asking
thank you any other questions I knew you
were G to do that representative
B thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question uh are you familiar
with Rhode Islands law I think it's very
similar to this they don't require a STi
for the first two years but they do have
uh I think it's a 20 or
$25,000 20 25,000 mile uh restriction uh
where you would have to have it
inspected um are you familiar with that
and how how does it work there and as
far as enforcement we seeing the lack of
a sticker for two years how does that
work and would
you be more likely to support the bill
and had a mileage limitation like that
uh so thanks for the question represent
um unfortunately I'm not familiar with
the Rhode Island program um I know um
you know the New Hampshire program as it
is um what I do know is that in other
states that have um weakened or
eliminated their safety inspection
program alog together what they have in
fact done is Empower law enforcement to
do a greater level of roadside
enforcement as far as mechanical and
safety items um so that's part of the
tradeoff um that's not what proposed
here um I'd be curious to see what uh
both state and local law enforcement
feel about um greater roadside safety
mechanical inspection you you can't see
brakes from the outside of a car you got
to get in and under them right um and
then the liability associated with that
so you let someone drive off and a mile
and a half down the road uh they slide
off the road um but law enforcement just
had the vehicle on the side of the road
a mile and a half earlier that liability
chain would would make me a little bit
nervous um but um whether that in fact
is included in the Rhode Island program
I do not know um it's a discussion if
you and I would like to to take a look
at it and chat about it but um I can't
say I no enough about it and certainly
to say that whether we would support it
or
not anybody else seeing none thank you
very much thank you Mr thanks for making
a liar of me I knew you couldn't get it
done in 5 minutes um next up chair
recognizes Tracy Boris representing the
Hampshire motorcyclist rights
organization uh opposed to the bill
looking for a couple of minutes
welcome thank you chairman Walsh
committee members I am Tracy borage I'm
the president of New Hampshire
motorcycle rights organization and just
to make you aware I'm also the chair of
the New Hampshire motorcycle safety task
force
I represent motorcycles on the New
Hampshire traffic and safety commission
I also sit on the board of the
motorcycle riders Foundation mrf which
is the national voice for motorcyclist
so I spend a lot of my time doing
motorcycling things in my spare time I
ride we're here because we've had many
many discussions over the years about
inspections um the the bond of our
organization the people that I represent
believe that inspections keep
motorcycles and cars safer mostly due to
the tires and the brakes and I can tell
you that there are many of us that ride
I have several friends that have bought
brand new bikes and put more than 50,000
miles on them in a season you can bet
that they need a new tire and if they're
not getting inspected this is not the
old school biker world where my husband
and a lot of our friends came from where
they looked at their tire tread or they
could change their brakes the New Riders
out there y'all have seen them on the
roads are disregarding the speed limits
and what what's happening so to keep us
safer I don't want to ride my motorcycle
by somebody like that but I also don't
want to ride my motorcycle with a
vehicle that may have tires or brakes
that are going to take me out so we are
asking that you look at that and
consider this because there are cars
that do the same thing that put many
more miles than they
average and that's all I have thank you
very much any questions from the
committee seeing n thanks again thank
you uh next up chair recognize
es and I should know this
tooon Aon Scott Aon the H State
Police in opposition to the bill seeking
five minutes welcome sir thank you Mr
chairman and me members of the
committee uh the state of State Police
would definitely oppose this um House
Bill 209 I'll just speak briefly I know
I put five minutes but I'll speak
briefly on um the concerns for law
enforcement um Mr Bennett covered a lot
of it the majority of the concerns would
be there's no two-year sticker process
in plan for this thing so law
enforcement potentially will be stopping
cars because they'll see a no inspection
even though it's a new car they'll see
no inspection they'll stop it and it
could get into at that time safety risk
for the officer roadside because now
he's stopping a vehicle roadside when
maybe he doesn't even need to because is
they're exempt um or it could lead to
other things where law enforcement might
find other issues with this car as far
as you know potentially violations not
not having to do anything with the car
but other violations that could
potentially turn into arrests and then
once we get into a judicial system with
this they could be you know what was the
reason for the Stop well it had no
sticker well it didn't need an ex
sticker was exempt and chances chances
of getting something tossed in court are
there for that as well um talked
about law enforcement having to do more
roadside mechanical inspections I know
they're newer vehicles but these
vehicles are now heavier because a lot
of them are electric a lot of them are
all-wheel drive they heat up tires
faster so now you'll have a law
enforcement officer out there
potentially walking around a car
roadside trying to determine if the
tires are good um stuff that they can
see so it's it's more of a risk for us
and concern especially where there's no
two-year sticker um Implement
implemented for this uh the commercial
motor vehicle sticker they have to have
a federal annual
so we used in New Hampshire they
recognize our state inspection as a
federal annual sticker so that helps
that helps the um commercial motor
vehicle industry because they don't have
that that covers their Federal annual so
law enforcement sees a New Hampshire
valid inspection sticker on that CMV we
know it has a federal annual sticker
it's good to go new vehicles if this
applies to them now we don't see that
sticker so now we got to go looking for
the federal annual and they put they put
those in a different location which
aren't visible a lot of times to law
enforcement so now you got a law
enforcement Trooper out there roadside
trying to walk around a truck to find
the federal annual sticker so those are
just some of the concerns I won't cover
it um any of the other ones because most
of them were covered but these newer
Vehicles they do wear out TI tires are
probably the biggest thing and I know
that we're supposed to all look at our
ties to make sure but I can tell you
from I have my son he's got a brand new
2000 tracks I looked at his tires the
other day Saturday year and his TIR is a
warn out I put a tread front tires a
worn out because it's front-wheel drive
so I put a tread depth there 330 seconds
so two years on a new car it's great if
somebody's watching what they're doing
but if they're not they're going to wear
out their ties and they might not even
know until it's too late and it's winter
and they're sliding off the road so
those are just some of the concerns law
enforcement has um and I'd be happy to
answer any questions that you might have
for me thank you sir any questions from
the committee represent
SES is it safe to say that uh winter
driving conditions will also impact on
how tires perform and we have a um as I
recall from previous testimony that New
Hampshire has some of the more
interesting winter
weather that is that's true we run into
that now currently whether it's whether
they get a valid state inspection not
more times than not especially this time
of year cars that are going off the road
yes it's due to the speed related but a
lot of the times it's due to their tires
are just they might not be below the
inspection requirements but they're
they're worn out for winter driving um
so yeah we run into that a lot and and a
lot of times with these accidents that's
what we see it's the tires I mean you
can't really see the brakes without
taking tires off so a lot of times it's
Tire related issues um the cars are
heavier especially the electric cars
those are a lot heavier and the
all-wheel drive cars because my wife has
an all-wheel drive car and I'm like how
are we eating tires up so fast but they
just eat them up fast because they're
you know you buy a softer tire for the
winter and um we wear them out faster so
yes in New Hampshire especially in the
Northeast the tires are crucial and
making sure you know getting them
checked once a year that's good we don't
you know I don't I think going to plus
years to get somebody to actually a
mechanic to look at a car to make sure
the T I know it's the owner but a state
inspection every year in the state we're
trying to keep the road safe in New
Hampshire um I think we do a good job of
that now and I would just hate to see
even though the new cars I would hate to
see that we would um blackx on our
safety level
there any other
questions Repro thank you Mr chair and
thank you officer for taking my question
um uh please please uh forgive me this
might be a little bit funny but like my
birthday is in
July we're in January right now let's
say tomorrow I go and buy a brand new
car and let's say is a part is it
possible for a part of the deal that
that new car could be inspected through
July 31st
2026 or am I in a situation where if I
buy that car tomorrow the longest I can
get for the inspection is July 2025
I believe it's the the what you said
through 26 two years from the time you
from the time you register 18 months but
18 not two
years two years would be the Max on
yours I think okay got it thank
you I'd have to look at the law to make
sure though okay any other questions
from the committee being none thank
thank you very much you're welcome thank
you so much and just a general question
I have not not to you but you ever
notice that when we talk about
inspection stickers electric vehicles
are much heavier than internal
combustion engine but when we're talking
about them parking in garages they're
not uh next up chair recognizes Michael
Fitzpatrick the Hamp Department um
Environmental
Services um does have Britten testimony
not take a position on the belill good
morning good morning Mr chair members of
the committee Michael Fitzgerald I'm the
assistant director of the air Resources
Division at the Department of
Environmental Services and I'm here
today to speak to the only the emissions
portion of the inspection program uh not
the safety we we run the uh inspection
program jointly with the Department of
Safety we work
cooperatively um to so that the
inspections are done concurrently um but
we have purview on the emissions
inspection uh just by way of History the
uh emissions inspection that we
currently have in New Hampshire is a
compromise that was arrived DED at back
in the early 2000s with EPA uh New
Hampshire as its status uh having
formally been in non-attainment
for um uh Federal pollution standards
and as a result of being in the ozone
transport region which is a f federally
designated uh area of the country
generally uh the States from Virginia
north um and so the Clean Air Act
requires under the uh requirements for
the ozone transport region Vehicle
Emission Inspection programs that's why
you uh we often get the question why do
different states have different
inspection requirements and we have a
more stringent inspection requirement um
in the ozone transport region so uh
those those States uh the New Hampshire
inspection is part of our New Hampshire
State implementation plan which is a
document that we submit to EPA they
approve and then it becomes federally
enforceable
so again we take no position on this and
we again I don't I'm not addressing the
safety portion of of this at all but on
the emissions inspection program um we
would lose some emission reductions and
those emissions reductions would have to
be made up by some other sector um we
would have to work with EPA in order to
uh have a revision to our state
implementation approved that generally
takes anywhere from 12 to 18 months so
our ask of the committee um I have here
uh which I'll share uh copies uh we we
sent a letter of testimony yesterday to
the entire committee I will share copies
of a letter from
EPA uh that was uh sent last year in
response to this spill that um
explaining the situation with our Sip
and the requirement to to change the Sip
so uh what we would ask is that if this
bill were to go forward that you give
consideration to language similar to uh
and I have put a link in our testimony
letter uh the currently proposed s SP
1557 relative to rental Fleet
inspections uh that I assume will come
to this committee later some point but
that that bill has language in it that
would allow the emissions inspection to
remain unchanged until such time as the
certifies to the Secretary of State that
uh we have had the a change to the uh
uh and that revision approved by EPA and
uh EPA does have the authority to uh
hold sanctions against the state that
was how we entered into this compromise
in the first place we were supposed to
have a tailpipe inspection strictly
reading the interpretation of the law
and New Hampshire negotiated the OBD uh
vehicle emissions inspection your check
engine light that everyone loves on your
vehicle um and so uh we would simply ask
that uh if this bill were to move
forward uh again not withstanding any of
the safety issues uh on the emissions
inspection that you consider language
similar to that in sb1
157 uh and I have uh copies of of the
letter to EPA and uh uh the sb17
language that I'll leave with the uh
chair and the secretary and be happy to
address any
questions thank you very much did
everybody receive the testimony online
from the Department it's actually
illustrates their position very well any
questions from the
committee seeing none thanks very much
and will certainly take anything you
have to offer written uh next up chair
recognizes director morasco from the
Department of Motor
Vehicles uh opposed to the bill welcome
back
sir thank you Mr chair members of the
committee uh there's a written testimony
that is uh being handed out um
most of the testimony that's you've
already heard uh I Echo it uh we we
oppose the bill my name is John morasco
director of the DMV uh we oppose the
bill and the written testimony
highlights the reasons why uh from our
standpoint on behalf of the Department
of Safety it's uh it's a safety issue
it's a program that works uh we don't
receive a large number of complaints
about the program we do get a complaint
that comes in uh for predatory
inspections or anything along those
lines uh we work with our state police
partner ERS and automotive equipment
inspectors who go out and do a followup
and an audit and if there's an issue
that's brought forth um the inspection
station or or mechanic could be brought
in for a hearing um but like I said we
uh we also have seen a um and I
testified last session on this a growth
in in transparency for inspections I use
groni Mazda here in coch as an example
we went toward uh their inspection
facility uh not only did they give you a
video after the inspection um and the
mechanic goes through the different
points uh that may have come up short
during the inspection but you can also
look through the window and see the
inspection take place so um again we
oppose the bill we think the program
works and uh happy to take any
questions thanks sir any questions from
the committee representative Hill thank
you Mr chairman and thank you director
for taking my question uh is there
anything in the bill that um uh prohibit
someone from voluntarily uh having their
their vehicle expected within those two
years I'd have to look at the bill again
on that I'm not sure not sure off hand
do we have excuse followup followup do
we have a a way
um for someone to volunteer well U I
guess every inspection station would
just have the ability for having someone
stop in and ask for a voluntary
inspection does that do we have that do
they get an updated I'm getting nods I
think I've got my answer question thank
you thank
you I'm going to follow up on that that
I hear you correctly now in voting
worlds you can volun you can pull over a
Marine Patrol and voluntarily have them
go through your vehicle and if you comp
if you comply with all the regulations
and safety they give you a little
sticker on the window that says you
voluntarily did this do we have
something like that for automobiles I'd
have to check I have not heard of that
no we did not I think it's a wonderful
idea but thank you uh any other
questions from the
committee seeing none thank you sir
thank you Mr
chair uh I have nobody else signed up to
speak uh on where are we House Bill 209
so I'll close the public hearing uh last
hearing for the day scheduled for we're
running a little bit behind but still
we're going to take a couple of minutes
to stretch our legs uh next up in a few
minutes House Bill 239 FN uh see you
then
e
e e
welcome back everybody I'm going to open
up the public hearing on house bille 239
FN defining and enabling Lane filtering
chair recognizes the prime sponsor
representative Reed welcome thank thank
you Mr chair and thank you honorable
members um for the record my name is
Ellen Reed I represent Rockingham 10
that is New Market and new Fields um
also for uh background on myself um in
terms of why I brought this bill forward
um I have been riding motorcycles for 18
years um I've ridden in I believe 17
States about a third of the states I
think um I've ridden in seven countries
I've lost track of the number of
motorcycles I've written which I have to
say I don't own as many as I've tried
that would be representative gon with
his stable of dozens of very expensive
bikes um which I've had the pleasure of
seeing but uh the point being that I I
think I I I at least have 100,000 miles
under my belt on two
wheels so Lane filtering and I just
wanted to find Lane filtering I know you
can read the bill but Lane filtering is
when a motorcycle specifically two
wheels goes between lanes or depending
on if you're like right on top of the
line or slightly to the side of the line
um shares a lane with a uh car either at
a stoplight or in extremely slow traffic
like in
construction um lane splitting which is
a term you may see in testimony or may
hear is an umbrella term that includes
that behavior which is only at super low
speed or stopped traffic but also what
California does and California is the
only one where it's fully legal um which
is Lane share like lane splitting at
speed at at the speed limit this is not
that that lane splitting this is just
the very narrow Lane filtering that only
happens at um stopped traffic or very
slow
speeds specifically 10 miles an hour or
less um so 17 states have lane splitting
legal six of which have um affirmative
affirmatively uh provided for protection
of motorcycles to engage us Behavior to
choose whether or not to engage in that
behavior as is their right um and almost
the ENT ire world and I can say this
from having just this past year ridden
across a significant piece of Europe um
Poland Italy France honestly if there
wasn't Lane filtering in most of those
countries especially in the cities the
traffic would never move because such a
large percentage of the population uh
rides on two wheels that it's the only
way to mitigate the traffic this is also
true southeast Asia and a large part of
South America so most of the world
recognizes Lane filtering at slower
stopped traffic as just proper traffic
management and the reason it's proper
traffic management is because
motorcycles because of their power to
weight ratio have acceleration
capabilities better than pretty much any
consumer produced automobile that is
available um and so if you're in traffic
you want all the vehicles to get out of
that traffic as quickly as possible and
motorcycles are doing that by getting
themselves out of traffic they can only
do that if they can get up to the front
of the
line the particular legislation here is
based
on Colorado I think Colorado's language
but I added in Minnesota's education
piece and protection um against
aggressive automobile behavior and I'll
get into um that so I just mentioned
that traffic flow is one of the biggest
reasons
one of it's not the biggest reason for
this uh another reason which is not the
biggest reason is to protect
motorcyclists who are sitting on a
combustion engine usually in summer
weather in traffic usually wearing full
gear so motorcyclists can easily become
overheated and their motorcycles which
do not have the kind of cooling systems
that cars have can also become
overheated so allowing them to leave
traffic sooner helps with that but
that's also not the biggest reason to
allow this the biggest reason to allow
this is because a motorcycle sitting
behind and I think anyone here who's
ridden knows this problem very well
sitting behind at a stoplight behind a
full automobile does not add to that
silhouette and a person approaching you
from behind doesn't necessarily see that
you are closer to them than the
silhouette that they see which is the
rear end of the car in front of you
which means that motor M cyclists are at
a huge risk of rearin collisions when
they are sitting in traffic as they are
legally required to do
currently and those rear end collisions
are incredibly fatal in fact one of um
not just fatal but can result in other
severe injuries one of the um people who
I think has reached out to you or will
reach out to you is the person who made
this bill um become law in
Minnesota and the he was he's either the
president or high up in the BMW
motorcycle um Owners
Association and he had his wife on the
back of his BMW sitting as he was
legally supposed to do in traffic and
got rear ended as frequently happens and
his wife um lost use of her legs I don't
know if it was temporary or or permanent
but um a very very severe injury um and
that spurred him to get this law passed
in
Minnesota so that safety and very
specifically the option the option to
choose the safer um option on the road
for the motorcyclist this is the Live
Free or Die State I know we can all come
up with examples where we don't
necessarily think that is true but we
don't have helmet law in this state we
don't have seat belt law in this state
and for some reason we are requiring
motorcyclists to engage in a more
dangerous Behavior now if a particular
motorcyclist maybe somebody who isn't as
experienced is afraid of going in
between the vehicles that's their option
they can sit they can stand or sit
behind a car that's fine this is about
the right to make the choice for what is
in your best interest I will say that if
you never practice going in between
Vehicles you are denying yourself a very
necessary skill because there will be
times in traffic again anyone who spent
significant time on two wheels knows
there will be times in traffic that you
have to react quickly and you have to
maneuver in a tight situation so if you
never do that you are a worse road
hazard than when you get the experience
to actually do that and this is you can
watch videos of European Riders South uh
Asian Riders riding and you would be
surprised at the the ride skill that
they have because we just don't practice
those skills
here so the specifics of when this is
allowed in the bill um
any traffic that's traveling less than
10 m an hour for a vehicle that has two
wheels on the ground so this is
important this is not a trike this is
not a spider this is not a motorcycle
with a side car this is very
specifically a two- wheeled
vehicle um in contact with the ground so
like if you had a spare mounted that
would be different but also you can't do
a wheelie while you're Lane
filtering um Can overtake in between
lanes so not on shoulders but in between
lanes uh if the traffic is traveling at
less than 10 m an hour and as long as
the motorcycle is going 20 M an hour or
less so that speed differential is
really important that's a a 10 m hour
speed differential there are Studies by
dot Studies by UC Berkeley um multiple
studies that have shown not there also
other studies that show that sitting
behind as a motorcycle sitting behind a
c uh the stop light is a huge rear and
collision risk which I failed to mention
earlier but there are studies that show
that as much as we continually say in
it's popular narrative that speed kills
which is true or your overall speed is a
is the number one um risk factor it's
actually not overall speed yes speed is
a factor especially given the road
you're on and and other things but the
speed differential in most cases when
we're talking about vehicle and vehicle
collision speed differential and this is
from these studies is the most important
factor in a collision so so and so much
so that they actually have an exact
number 15 M an hour speed differential
is where things get dangerous and you
are more likely to cause a traffic
Hazard or a a risk of collision if
you're going slower on that slow side so
if you are going 15 mil an hour slower
than traffic is even if traffic is going
20 miles an hour over the speed limit if
you're going 50 m hour or more slower
you are creating the risk more so than
if you're going 15 miles an hour faster
than traffic but the goal is to get
everybody within that same 15 mph window
because that is where collisions don't
typically happen so this is a 10 m an
hour speed
differential but I want to bring up
because one of the big um arguments will
be something along the lines of you know
well you could potentially if it's
narrow you could potentially hit uh
Vehicles as you're going in between
um that's true anytime you operate any
kind of vehicle you need to know the
width of your vehicle and while safety
for cars or advancements in safety for
cars focuses on the engineering aspect
of cars you know creating crumple zones
and better frames and airbags and what
have you safety for
motorcycles really is all on the rider
anyone who rides motorcycles knows that
they are taking on all the risk and they
have to drive defensively because if
there is a problem and when you're in an
accident on a motorcycle you are 30
times more likely to die from that
accident than in a
car so you need to know how wide your
vehicle is no matter what you're driving
you need to know whether or not you can
fit in whatever area you're driving into
no matter what you're
driving um and you're taking on that
risk as a person who's operating a
vehicle so that's true across the board
but what I will say is that if you're
sitting behind a vehic vehicle and you
are uh about to be rear ended that is a
much worse Collision than if you go in
between lanes and you tap a mirror and
it's like 95% of all of those Lan
filtering incidents are mirror Taps and
all that results of it is having to
readjust your mirrors so that's not to
say that other things can't happen but
that's the vast majority and I would
much rather be all day long every day in
a mirror tap incident than a rear end
rear end incident
okay so I think I am on to uh the
education piece this was borrowed out of
Minnesota's
language um I think that's kind of
self-explanatory um education for both
the motorcyclist in our um training but
also I think education for car drivers
because I think anyone who's ridden
motorcycles knows that there are
aggressive cars people who just really
hate motorcycles and have done things
intentionally to risk motorcyclist lives
that is something that we deal with
that's a risk that we take on is being
aware and being able to evade those um
so the question one of the questions
that um about this bill is well drivers
are just going to be mad that these
motorcycles are passing them and coming
up to the front of the line and you know
yeah there probably will be a few mad
drivers at first and that's why there's
an education to let people know it's
legal but again this is the law of the
land pretty much everywhere else in the
world and drivers are okay with it they
get used to it it's weird in this
country that we kind of approach driving
from this kind of
individualistic um it's my turn it's
your turn perspective rather than what's
in the best interest of traffic flow
perspective and that's something that
the rest of the world kind of emphasizes
but eventually it will be
normalized um and that's part of why the
education now I $110,000 is is10 to
$100,000 is in the fiscal Noe is
possible for that education I don't see
how um maybe adding a little tiny
segment to motorcycle education and then
doing maybe a press release social media
release and maybe some LED signs would
exceed $10,000 but I'm sure that there
are people here who will be eager to
speak to what they think the cost will
be and I guess I'm just going to close
with um the idea
that I think a lot of times we all not
just in this building but in our lives
make decisions based on feeling rather
than fact and there's definitely a
feeling there's General feelings I think
for all of us that we're reticent to
change we like things the way they are
we're used to that um and there's also
the feeling that there's this stereotype
of the motorcyclist that is this young
typically male kind of Reckless Rider
the majority of writers are not young
and not Reckless they're usually
middle-aged and they've chosen
motorcycles because it's a more cost
efficient time efficient and fuele
efficient way to get between their
locations that they need to commute and
they're willing to take on um the cost
which is increased risk to themselves
that's most Riders and I would like to
say that female writers are the fastest
growing demographic in m cycle riding um
so there is this emotional thing like oh
this is going to be a bunch of
halfhazard
aggressive Riders but that's actually
not true most of the motorcyclists are
actually responsible and have very
knowingly and conscientiously taken on
these risks and understand how to engage
in risk
management and um I just think that
given that there's study after study
that shows that this is a danger to
motorcyclist and that we are in the lify
OR dice State it's only the right thing
to do to join the multiple States and
most of the world in allowing
motorcyclist to make that decision for
themselves as to what is in the best
interest of their safety and with that
I'm happy to take
questions thank you any questions from
the committee representative
G thank you Mr chair thank you uh
representative Reed so as of right now
when I am on my motorcycle and I come in
to stop traffic you know I I don't want
to get sandwiched any more than anybody
else that's one of the uh that's
actually one of my only fears on a bike
I have no fear on a bike except for
getting
sandwiched um right now I will pull out
and I could get cited for failure to uh
maintain a singular Lane of traffic for
pulling out of the flow as the only
option to getting rear ended now if I
pull far enough to the edge of a lane I
have had cars come up and try to
encroach me off the lane this bill would
give me the option to at safe speeds not
only get out of in between the vehicles
but also filter to a safe location
whether it's the next turn or this front
of the line correct that's absolutely
correct representative and I'm thank you
for pointing out that I failed to
mention that based on Minnesota law this
does make illegal the Hostile behavior
of intentionally blocking a motorcycle
that is trying to Lane filter um
currently you could be cited if you
engaged in the safest behavior and again
riding a motorcycle while you and I both
consider it to be fun um is a service to
society you are saving emissions you are
saving on traffic you're saving on
parking you're doing a service so much
so that a lot of other countries and a
lot of States reward motorcyclists by
with close parking um with uh lower
tolls with use of the HOV lane um so we
reward this Behavior that's helping with
our traffic problems so why would we
penalize motorcyclists when they're just
trying to do what is
safest and quick follow up follow up and
there is nothing in this bill that
mandates me doing this you've seen my
bikes and I have couple that are a
little bit
wider and I would not be comfortable
doing that with them there's nothing
that mandates that I use this right if
you had a big fat boy with big giant
saddle bags or what have you um you
don't have to do it there's nothing this
is just a motorcyclist rights
issue any other questions from the
committee represent Miller uh thank you
Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question um you mentioned at one point
sort of clear traffic and I have been in
Southeast Asia and see all the
motorcycles come up and they sort of end
up in the crosswalk if they bother to
stop so um but when the light changes
they go and everybody goes out behind
the cars go out behind them I've seen
that happen I understand that our roads
I feel like don't necessarily have a
space at the front of the front of the
line behind the intersection behind the
crosswalk for motorcycles to stop or
other two whe vehicles to stop is there
a situation where you're going to have
you know sort of two vehicles next to
each other trying to figure out who goes
first and how that gets sorted or how do
you see that playing out and from a
safety perspective mostly so I can
guarantee you and I think rep gon's
going to back me up on this one um if
there's a motorcycle stopped at the same
line as a car that motorcycle's going
first there's no question we can
accelerate faster than you could ever
dream of unless you have the highest end
race car and I have maybe a not great
bike that's the only way that that the
car is going to win that that battle
having said that you do bring up a good
point which is a lot of communities
elsewhere have created these specific
zones because such a large percentage of
their population rides on two wheels we
don't have that high of a percentage of
population if you're at a stoplight
currently you don't see unless it's
maybe the height of Like Bike Week
season you don't see dozens of two-
wheeled Vehicles waiting at that
stoplight um having said that there's
nothing preventing any community that
has jurisdiction of whatever that road
is whether it's a Town Road or or state
from creating those zones at
intersections to allow like kind of the
parking space for them in the front of
the line but typically you're going to
see Matt most maybe one bike at a
stoplight and that bike will be nose to
noose with the car next to it and the
bike will get in front and the if the if
the car driver is upset about that it's
not a problem because they'll forget all
about that bike in about 5 Seconds
representative foot thank you Mr
chairman thank you representative Reed
do we know in those States the 17 states
where this is legal is there any studies
or um statistics about any increased
accidents with vehicles doing this
because I know it's a big education
component to this with riders and
regular Vehicle drivers so is there any
uptick and accidents when this first
gets initiated or I have the person who
may or may not have reached out to you
already um um who has that information
for you um I don't know if it's been in
all of those states where it's so 12 of
the states 11 of the states it's just
legal because there's no law that speaks
to it and six of them have proactively
made it a behavior for motorcyclists to
engage in um so um I'm happy to get that
information from that person or anywhere
else and send it along to the committee
having said that once again those
accidents are going to be mirror taps or
very slow speed side swipes which is so
much better so much better than a rear
end at 20 30 miles an
hour further questions from the
committee I'll ask one myself statistics
wise uh because I'm obviously concerned
about motorcycle safety as well I got
you beat by a few years on the roads but
um how many but also how many years
you've been on the planet so maybe I'll
catch up to you um how many how many uh
incidents a year are we looking at for
fatalities or or actually reun
collisions of fatalities in the H do you
know once again that person who I just
cited has compiled all these statistics
and I'm happy I don't have a a specific
but I think the most important thing is
not the overall number it's the
percentage likelihood a motorcycle will
be rear ended at a stoplight versus a a
car because cars get rear-ended at stop
lights too right motorcycles are more
likely to be rear-ended and I can get
the data that shows you how much more
likely they are that would be
helpful um and I was hoping there'd be
somebody from the do here only the
actual definition itself uh because it
does specify in line nine that we're
only talking about passing or overtaking
in the same Lane do you have any idea
because I don't have a DOT person here
how wide the average Lane is in New
Hampshire versus how wide the normal
vehicle is or average vehicle in other
words if you do the subtraction there's
not much left there it depends on on
what road you're on so Highway lanes are
far wider than um a lot of like say town
roads uh the maximum width of a vehicle
I can tell you from being CDL for 13
years or 14 years whatever is 8 and a
half feet so a lane typically is like at
least 10 feet wide um but you know there
may be some very very small roads in
some very rural back areas that are
slightly more narrow I don't know what
the actual minimum is and there's
certainly Highway lanes that are far
wider um having said that once again if
you are the operator of any vehicle it
is on you your responsibility to know
how wide your vehicle is and if it can
fit where you're about to put it that's
true of a car a bus uh anything and so
you are taking on that responsibility
and I will just add that unlike in a car
or an SUV or a truck or whatever I can
maybe not on the fat boy but I can look
all around me and see exact exactly how
wide my vehicle is which is something I
don't get to do in a truck or a bus
right so I can see yeah no I'm
definitely not going to fit um but as a
motorcyclist you're taking on that risk
it the damage is on you so I just said
car versus motorcycle at a stoplight
motorcycle wins every single time the
downside the risk we all take on is car
versus motorcycle in a collision the car
wins every single time that's the
tradeoff anybody else from the committee
seeing none thank you very much thank so
much we got
here next up chair recognize Dan Bennett
H Auto Dealers Association opposed to
the bill looking for a couple of
minutes thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee I'll do my best to be
brief better than the last time again
Dan Bennett New Hampshire Auto Dealers
Association uh trade Association
represent the motor vehicle industry um
including multiple motorcycle and Power
Sports members um as I mentioned before
and you've heard me say before uh safe
roads is a Cornerstone issue for New
Hampshire Auto Dealers Association we're
a member of the New Hampshire Traffic
Safety commission we're a member of the
New Hampshire motorcycle safety task
force um and you've often heard us be a
roadway safety Advocate on issues
whether it's um inspections like before
uh the texting B B while driving U
motorcycle rider education um and uh
driver's education for young young
children who um may be in need and need
a scholarship we with a few of our
partners help administer a program to
help kid more kids get into driver's ed
so again roadway safety is an important
issue for us um it's our opinion uh that
Laden filtering at any speed is not
appropriate for New Hampshire um there's
going to be a huge driver and operator
um education curve um with this type of
issue both classroom and experiential um
if you've ever been um had it happen to
you especially at high speeds it can be
rather jarring um when someone overtakes
you um acknowledging that this is done
at the lower speed that we heard the
references to um to other places you
know the congestion that we experience
in New Hampshire is not California and
New York um it is not southeast Asia and
it is not European cities either uh 10 m
hour on 93 or 101 uh does not really
happen all that frequent ly um so um as
mentioned um and you've heard us before
recent data shows whether it's
impairment whether it's
distraction um whether it's excessive
speeds which if we we've seen records of
excessive speeds um over the past uh
year and summer especially um and
Mechanicals U it's it's just our opinion
this is not the right time uh to pass a
law that potentially uh could risk the
roads being um unsafe a little more
unsafe leading to accidents or
potentially even worse so um with that
being said uh Mr chairman uh that's all
I have to offer on this particular
legislation thank you very much
questions from the committee seeing none
thank you again thank you Mr chair
members next up chair recognizes Tracy
bourage representative the hire
motorcycle rights
organization opposed to the bill and I
have written testimony and written
testimony thank you
so I stated before um just to remind you
again I I represent motorcyclist across
the board in this state as the president
of New Hampshire motorcycle rights the
traffic and safety commission I chair
the task force and I sit on the national
board for motorcyclist so I'm very
involved very engaged and very aware of
motorcycling and what's going on in this
country um I have been riding since I
was 4 years old and I am older than she
is so longer than Miss Ellen
Reed we are here to oppose this bill and
obviously I represent the rights
organization we do believe in the rights
but it's a privilege to be on our roads
there's some things I want to um to
express as to why we feel that this is
an issue the first being the potential
impact of impaired Reckless and
distracted motor vehicle operators not
knowing or
understanding the legality of authorized
Lane filtering by
motorcyclist the second is given the
number of OU ofate motor vehicle
operators that we have that come in that
may not understand that we have this law
if we put this through the third uh
representative Reed mentioned $10,000 to
$100,000 having worked with the state on
the motorcycle rights or the motorcycle
funds that we do receive for the task
force I can tell you to implement this
it will not be $110,000 we can spend
that on
PSA for just the Riding community in in
just one riding season easily so knowing
that where is that cost going to come
from and given in the year where the
budget is being cut I doubt that we're
going to get that kind of money for this
I also want to let you know that most
motorcyclists uh and it took me a while
to understand too because we don't do it
and while I agree that it's happening in
Europe there are a lot more riders in
Europe that ride motorcycles it's very
common in our states most places we see
a lot of riders but it's still not a
common place for us compared to the
amount of vehicles on the
road motorcyclists most of them
themselves do not understand what lane
splitting or Lane filtering is and the
definition between the two in my
testimony I don't want to get into all
the details it does explain what is
generally accepted for filtering and for
splitting but if they don't know the
difference and yes there's an
educational comp component but do you
really think we're going to be able to
get to every motorcyclist that's riding
in this community and to the motorist
and explain to them that this is an
acceptable thing to do just this past
season September I had two different
motorcyc CES do what I would call lane
splitting at very high speeds down
between the line one was a Harley full
dresser the other was what we call a
crotch rocket and I can tell you in my
car I was pissed off it's not and I'm a
writer it's not acceptable the other
thing I want to tell you is typically
and you know she said this and this is
on them but this is huge because I deal
with this nationally the perception of
motorcyclist from other vehicle
operators is not good and it's not
because most of us are bad Riders it's
not because most of us are popping the
wheelies like what you're seeing out
there on the roadways but motorcyclists
have a very negative
negative feel for most other vehicle
operators they think that we all are
jerks and they think we all pop wheelies
and Rod like jerks so given that again
how are we going to Ed educate in that
component and explain to these people
that we're not being a jerk because the
next side is going to be well if they
can do it why can't I we're not ask
going to go down the breakdown Lane I
realize that but that will be the next
thing for other
vehicles
the states that she mentioned you have
this in my testimony as well there are
five states currently that have Lane
filtering and in that you'll see if you
look in my testimony I don't want to get
into every one of them exactly what
their lanee filtering in that state
allows and what it
says those five states though are like
Arizona Utah Colorado Montana do those
States sound like anything like New
Hampshire they've got roadways that
don't have a lot of people on them they
do have congestion in some areas
California lane splitting is legal it
has been only legal fairly recently I
think it's
2016 but California is a very different
state than New Hampshire New Hampshire
is not ready for this doesn't mean that
it won't ever be doesn't mean that we
won't have discussions in the future to
decide the other last thing that I'd
like to bring up is cheering the task
force the motorcycle task force and
there are some very Heavy Hitters on
that task force we have the department
of safety the Department of
Transportation The Liquor Commission uh
triaa uh New Hampshire Automobile
Dealers Association Nitsa New Hampshire
I mean uh the National Highway traffic
safety administration and the fars we
discuss a lot of this at length a lot of
this and a big component is we get every
single week I personally get the data of
what the crashes and fatalities are we
are not being hit from behind and that's
not to say that we can't ever be but we
don't need to change something that's
going to create more issues because we
might be that to me is not an
intelligent decision for us to spend
this money on
and with that I will take any questions
if you'd like but my testimony at the
very back if you will look to for those
of you that don't know what it is shows
you what that looks like if you're in
cars and that is coming down between the
lanes for most people it's not going to
be an acceptable action that doesn't
again mean that I agree or disagree it's
just I don't believe representing the
motorcyclist in the state that this is
the best thing for the state
thank you questions from the committee
representative London thank you Mr chair
thank you for your testimony for my
question I'm looking for some
clarification we've heard a lot of
testimony today
referencing motorcycles in Europe and
Asia my understanding a lot of those are
mopeds in those foreign countries a
higher percentage and that that's a from
what I've seen legally and as I'm a
motorcycle rider and I've got mopeds
they're totally different
Vehicles do you have any knowledge under
this uh European and and Asian is it is
it in fact an overwhelming amount of
motorcycles or am I correct in assuming
it's a mixture of mopeds and motorcycles
it's a mixture I don't have the numbers
um Larry Crow actually might be able to
tell you that more because he races over
there when he
testifies um but there are a lot smaller
typically I mean in India they a lot
smaller but but plenty of people over
there ride big like she said fat boys
and other types of motorcycles that are
full dressers um but a lot of those
people that are riding in other
countries are riding for a mode of
transportation in New Hampshire I can
tell you that the BR of the people
riding we're riding because we're bikers
we're not riding as a motor
Transportation it's a way of life for us
it's a it's a lifestyle to ride a
motorcycle thank you thank you Mr thank
you repres g
thank you Mr chair thank you ma'am so I
want to make sure that I'm understanding
your testimony correct in
that you um you are concerned more about
the culture being not ready causing an
additional risk to the biker and that's
that's your Prime reason for opposing
this is that you don't feel that the
culture is ready it's not anything other
than that is that correct no that's a
huge component of it but I think too
anything that we do we have have to
educate people correct and how again we
we have people we have motorcyclists
right now that are they're riding 160
miles an hour we had two that were
stopped this past year so we have
motorcycles engaging in Behavior that's
already illegal so we need to educate
those Riders but we need to educate the
the general public we're the general
public that doesn't know what a solid
white lawn means how many of you have
been in with in other places that don't
understand the solid white line so it's
not that that's the biggest component
but that is a component that we have to
think about and then we have to think
about funding that and to educate all of
these people and educate people coming
into our state is a it's going to be a
big issue and I don't think that we had
somebody at the mall of hire what was it
a year ago or two where it got cut off
and he shot somebody I would prefer not
to see motorcyclist having that issue
and where we're not seeing the data if
we were getting rear ended a
obviously this would probably be a very
different discussion but we're not we're
not being rear ended at a
stoplight you know in droves in New
Hampshire we're just not so the
fatalities and the crashes aren't aren't
showing us that we need to be talking
about this and while I agree that there
are top that we can be hit from behind
we are we have to be responsible on our
motorcycles to know what and where and
how and what to
do thank you for your question
representative pataro thank you Mr chair
and uh thank you for taking my question
um could could you describe what the
difference between splitting and
filtering is so I so if you look let me
get to the page I'm and I'm going to
read it only because again I happen not
to not to do it okay have I ever done it
yes one time lane splitting is generally
defined as riding on a multi-lane
highway such as a limited access freeway
a motorc cyclist could split the lanes
and ride between two vehicles if traffic
is heavily congested or
stopped Lane filtering is generally
defined as riding in multiple Lanes of
traffic where there are intersections
and signals a motorcycles could filter
between two rows a vehicle stopped at a
light allowing the motorcyclist to move
to the front of the
line but if you think about what those
two things say how many people do you
know are going to probably understand
filtering from
splitting thank you for your question
thank you that's great any other
questions from the committee seeing none
thank you very much thank you for your
time and the opportunity to
speak next up chair recognizes Larry
Crow represent Department of Motor
Vehicle motorcycle rider
training no position taken on the
bill good
afternoon good afternoon uh chairman
Walsh and committee members um thank you
for the opportunity to speak um I am the
state coordinator of the motorcycle
rider education program which is at the
division of motor vehicles um I'm not
here to speak for or against but to
provide any kind of information you may
need um I have uh a couple areas that
I'd like to speak to uh one thing that's
been mentioned tremendously here is the
educational component of putting any
kind of uh law like this in place um so
the uh motorcycle writer education
program operates within the Division of
Motor Vehicles it has been identified
within the bill as the entity to develop
the educational guidelines um where this
bill to pass it would be of the utmost
importance that the motor uh that the
motorcycling Community as well as the
passenger vehicle community in general
fully understand what it means and what
it does not mean for the continued safe
and legal operation of two- wheeled
motor vehicles uh Lane filter does have
the potential to be instituted very well
it can also be instituted very poorly
and education is the key difference
under the guidance of director morasco
uh mrep motorcycle rider education
program would be able to provide all the
support requested as the primary program
in the state that provides information
to the writing public and in particular
new writers we would need to devote
energy to fully understand the law is
written and as it is written it's it is
um easily understood uh by the
program um and create an outreach
program it would require training uh to
the instructor team to be able to impart
this information to the Riders as well
as answer questions from the public um
however the motorcycle rider education
program itself only directly touches a
small percentage of New Riders and
reaches very little of the existing
motor vehicle community in other words
car drivers
um who would be impacted by this
legislation as such an effective
Outreach campaign that reaches everyone
impacted would need to be created and
implemented and this is likely to
involve stakeholders from outside of the
DMV and the motorcycle rider education
program um uh I myself am a uh a rider I
have um I annually ride in Europe as
well as um I've ridden in um 48 of the
50 states you can probably guess which
two I haven't made it to yet um uh I
lived in Los Angeles where I daily rode
my r100 RT BMW um and uh lane splitting
was done regularly there I also um as I
mentioned ride extensively in Europe uh
just last year um much to my wife's
Chagrin who was sitting on the back of
the bike I was laye filtering and Prague
um and I can tell you if I hadn't done
that I would still be in Prague that
being said um New Hampshire is um
doesn't have a Prague yet so um uh it's
up you know yes it is done do I wish um
on a personal level that the United
States was um just blanket ready for
this um and in particular in New
Hampshire the unintended consequences of
potential road rage and um and other
kind of crashes is something to be
considered as you folks do make your
decision um you know that being said uh
the cost benefit analysis um would tend
to be toward you know does New Hampshire
need it um even though it's done well in
the rest of the country
um uh one one item would be um that uh
it would have to have tremendous
cooperation amongst everybody on the
road um with an eye with the good for
all not just the good for me um recent
behavior on the roads does indicate that
may not be what the current climate is
out there in our roads um but I do hope
that we get to the point where that
would happen and um you know lane
splitting might make sense for New
Hampshire um I'll end my testimony there
and if you have any questions I will do
my best to answer thank you sir any
questions from the committee
Rimer uh thank you Mr chairman thank you
for your testimony uh you mentioned
needing to get additional stakeholders
involved to develop an effective
training program um do you think that is
reasonable within the10 to $100,000
budget that's been put in the fiscal
note here or is this how broad is that
going to be and where do you see that
the spending
requirements that's hard to tell um some
of the external stakeholders would be
able to provide some funding we have um
some great generous Partners in this
State some of them are on the motorcycle
task force which I am also part of um so
that is difficult to say in that 10 to
100,000 came from me um you know we
can't I we are also a member of the
State Motorcycle Safety Association
where uh folks that are have the same
position as I do Across the Nation
regularly meet and uh the list of states
um that Tracy provided I've spoke to
almost every one of those folks that
were required and implemented it in
general um they have said that the
educational component has proven to be
very difficult um another thing in here
I believe it has a um which is typically
uh the common U implemented 60-day after
signing um probably more time would be
needed um because of the
creation um and also implementation of
it education I cannot emphasize enough
how important it is to do it well if
this bill does pass did that answer your
question sir yeah thank you very much
anybody
else
see well we're just asking questions you
can thank them afterwards uh seeing none
thank you very much thank
you uh next up chair
recognizes excuse
me Matt Uchi from the Hampshire State
Police in opposition to the bill
thank you Mr chair good afternoon sir
howo
you so my name is mat mitui I'm with uh
New Hampshire State Police and we're in
opposition of this bill um this bill
will inevitably increase the amount of
crashes that we see I'll give you some
statistics that I have from the office
of Highway Safety um that were posed
earlier so in 2020 there were 56 motor
vehicle crashes resulting in
injuries um there were 104 fatalities 26
of those involved uh motorcycles and
82.6% of them the motorcycle operator
was at
fault um in 2021 there were 118
fatalities in New Hampshire 26 of those
22% um involved motorcycles
87.5% the motorcycle operator was at
fault um in 2023 there were 127
fatalities in New Hampshire 40 of them
31.5% involved
motorcycles this bill references um
developing educational guidelines which
you've heard testimony too um I think
that that's going to be challenging when
you talk about lane splitting and
filtering and it's not just the
motorcyclists that need to be educated
it is the entire public um there are
only five states which you heard
testimony too all of those states are
out in the midwest um Hawaii
Arizona um Montana Utah Colorado there's
no States up in the northeast or on the
East Coast that allow filtering and
there will be a misunderstanding as to
what filtering is opposed to um what
splitting
is uh this would also be very
challenging to enforce um if you talking
about 95 in holiday weekend and traffic
is um traveling at 5 miles an hour you'd
see motorcycles splitting Lanes um
filtering if you will if they're going
30 40 miles an hour there's no way to
enforce that um and the the majority of
public the hundreds of thousands of V
visitors that we have every year aren't
going to be expecting a vehicle to be
passing uh on the right or left as they
filter their way through traffic through
the state um when they go to do Lane
changes it's going to result in crashes
um the pros don't outweigh the cons as
it relates to safety um with filtering
even if you look at downtown conquered
people are going to be looking for
parking spaces um they're going to have
their turn signal on they're not going
to be expecting a vehicle to be coming
up on their right or their left um as
they go to turn into a a parking space
it's going to result in additional
crashes additional injuries potential
fatalities
um the traffic just isn't an issue um in
New Hampshire as it is in other states
like
California in general I think the the
motorcycle operators in the state are
less experienced than in southern and
western states where the climate is
better um you just don't get the the
same amount of hours um in general that
you do down south
um there will certainly be confusion as
it relates to filtering in in lane
splitting um even motorcyclists have a
difficult time defining that let alone
the the general
public uh and it will certainly increase
road rage um we see it now this will
this will increase road rage
um you know we we heard testimony as to
who goes first when you come up to a a
traffic light
um you could get into vehicles that are
trying to race um I I just don't see any
any benefit as it relates to safety with
this with this
law that's all I have right thanks uh
I'm going to throw one at you uh because
you did mention a good point about that
we don't have that type of traffic in
New Hampshire I'll disagree with you on
two days of the week Friday and Sunday
and it's usually on our interstates and
they are locked up for
hours what would your feeling be if
there was a law that said it was okay
for motorcycles at a low speed could use
the breakdown Lane in those
situations I wouldn't be in favor of it
um what what is the what is the benefit
um and it's if it's to alleviate traffic
we just don't have hundreds of thousands
of motorcycles that are traveling it's
it's its vehicles um yes it can be hot
on certain days but we don't have the
same climate and the same weather that
that you see in States like Arizona we
don't have the same roads and again the
the motoring public is not expecting
vehicles to be traveling in Breakdown
Lanes they're not expecting um
motorcycles to be traveling um down
middle Lanes so they're they're not
expecting it and I don't know how you
how you educate that unless it becomes a
more common practice across this country
not just in certain parts of this
country and it's not a common practice
up here and if we are the first state
that implements that in the Northeast uh
we're going to be the ones that that
have all the The Growing Pains so to
speak I'm breaking my own rule but you
asked me what the benefit would be and I
would say that the benefit probably is
that seeing us on most motorcycles are
air cooled uh preventing damage to my
motorcycle would be a benefit anybody
else from the committee
well represent
gas thank you Mr chair thank you
Trooper how often do you have instances
where a police car is turned into
sideswiped or otherwise damaged um when
it is passing by traffic um because I
know one of your points was that traffic
doesn't expect it you've got lights and
siren and they still surprise me do you
have a lot of side collisions from uh
civilians just turning into the police
car when you go buy
them I I don't have the
the statistics on that um it does happen
um but to your point if it's happening
when we have Audible lights and Sirens
um I can only imagine what's going to
happen when when motorcycles don't
they're hard to see already um we used
to
allow our motorcycle unit to pass um
with lights and siren During certain
escorts of vehicles and things like that
um but we did away with that due to
safety concerns and that is with
um with Visual and audible warnings to
the to the motoring public just because
they're not expecting it they're not
they're not looking for
it representative Crawford thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question how do you see this working at
the tolls because you know on July 4th
or all our big holidays even though we
have the 60 M hour straight through in
hookit I'm thinking hookit that's where
I travel the most um you still get a
backup and and if you're gonna pay a
toll you definitely get a backup do you
see a problem with uh motorcyclists
taking advantage of that with this new
law of passing cars through trying to
get through the 60 M hour lane or even
passing through trying to get ahead in
the pay you know the paying
Booth thank you for the question it
certainly could um again I I think that
the vast majority even though um
perception sometimes is is reality I
think the vast majority of motorcycle um
operators are good labing citizens that
want to do the right thing want to enjoy
this great state
um but when you're talking about the
other hundreds of thousands of motorists
who aren't familiar with the law it it's
going to result in road rage situations
with them trying to cut in I just sat in
traffic for the last three hours and now
I have a motorcycle that's going to come
in at the tolls potentially um
it it has disaster written all over it
um to be quite blunt um I just don't see
anything positive coming out of this
other than you know on real hot days the
the overheating um in in general I just
don't think that this is what this state
needs at this
time any other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much thank you uh last pink card I have
last person to sign up
uh I'm giving a cleanup to Dan Goodman
from the Triple
A uh opposed to the
Bill thank me
later and I'm just I'm just kidding by
the
way apologies uh chairman members of the
committee thank you for giving me a few
minutes uh for the record my name is Dan
Goodman I'm the public affairs and
traffic safety manager for tripa
Northern New England uh we represent
about a little over a million uh members
in Maine New Hampshire and Vermont we um
over the years advocate for public
policies to make our road safer here in
New Hampshire distracted driving impair
driving speeding and now uh Lane
filtering um I'm hear in opposition to
this it seems um as a very inherently
dangerous activity especially with the
increasing number of fatalities not just
motor vehicle fatalities but motor
motorcycle F fatalities that we're
seeing nationally and here in in New
Hampshire over the last um 20 years
we've seen uh motorcycle motorcycle
fatalities about 30 times higher than uh
automobile fatalities and over the last
five years here in New Hampshire
motorcycle fatalities have risen 20%
that's alarming when I was looking at
the data just six seven eight years ago
we were seeing motorcycle fatalities in
the teens and most recently in 2023
there was 40 motorcycle fatalities so
passing a law to
um allow in in our opinion inherently
dangerous activity um is not wise D
drivers may not be aware um of a
motorcycle passing them in the in the
Middle Lane and in fact in some of our
recent research where we looked at the
blind spot monitoring which is in most
new vehicles um they they they never
detected motorcycles or very rarely and
um we should say you
know we you know we advise motorists not
to rely on that but we found in that
research that motorist
over rely on their technology
specifically their blind spot monitoring
so they will be turning just in turning
without uh sometimes looking at their
blind spot and lastly um the conditions
of uh New Hampshire roads are a concern
in the latest National report 33% of our
roads are in poor in Med mediocre
condition and that's a concern uh for
not just motorcycles but automo
automobiles as well um so that is all so
much good stuff has been said so I'll
I'll just wrap it up quickly thankk you
than you for the time I'd be happy to
answer any
questions thank you sir any questions
from the committee seeing n thanks again
thank you all right last person I have
signed up so I will close the public
hearing on and I shouldn't have done
that where are
we
239 um so that concludes our public
hearings for today that was a method to
my madness our executive session is
scheduled for 1:30 I kind of had a
feeling this is going to happen so we'll
see you then what
Happ
e
e e
good afternoon everybody I'm sorry for
the delay once again we always like to
make sure we are as prepared as
possible we will get started by opening
up the executive session on House Bill
105 FN creating a new conservation
license plate and directing the
additional fee to the sign of bacteria
mitigation loan and Grant fund uh chair
recognizes representative Coker for a
motion thank you Mr chairman I make a
motion of ought to pass on House Bill
105 motion is ought to pass do I have a
second second by representative St Clair
do you wish to speak to your motion uh
yes sir sir so anything we can do to uh
help mitigate cob bacteria I'm a fan of
especially being from a district up in
Meredith at uh on lake wiip pasak so I
think this is a great way to help um
pull up the uh funds available to uh
fight it mitigate it and it kind of
prevents some of these um Waterfront
towns from having their taxes get jacked
up for the mitigation efforts which can
be a huge increase and it's voluntary so
it's uh I think it's a win-win for
everybody and I think it's also going to
be a really good marketing vessel too I
mean the that's going to be a cool
license plate and people are going to
see it around all around New England so
I like
it thank you sir anybody else from the
committee representative SES yeah I I'm
in favor of the a to pass motion I I
think that it's um I'm I will just
express some skepticism about the costs
involved that that the organization will
I don't I don't see it as a revenue
producing device but I do think it has
very important public uh relations
benefits very important benefits for uh
bringing this issue to the Forefront and
for that reason I could support the bill
anybody else from the
committee no all right seeing none um
the motion is ought to pass on House
Bill 105 I'll ask the clerk to call the
role one she's
ready uh Vice chairman Gorski yes clerk
votes yes representative
Hill no representative foot yes
representative
poo yes representative Coker yes
representative gon yes representative
Hamlin yes representative Sykes yes
representative Sinclair yes
representative Fox
yes representative veu yes
representative Johnson yes
representative
pondon yes and representative Miller yes
and chairman Walsh yes consent 15 to
one okay um our recommendation is
adopted for out to pass I should say 15
to1 I did hear somebody move consent who
was that without uh is there a second
for consent
second without any without any objection
consent that
is um 10 you know what hold on one
second should turn it's 25
so
okay that's
right don't mind me just for the record
I'm just getting caught up on uh the
paperwork which which were second
committee bills and which were not put
it this way we're on the record of being
okay with it if we we can put it on
consent we will if not it will not be
there so I'll close the executive
session on House Bill
105 uh next up after a few minutes of
reset uh we'll be doing House Bill
e e
slight change plans folks we're waiting
on a few
Amendment uh so the next bill we take up
will be House Bill 133
okay I'm going to open up the executive
session on House Bill 133 FN modifying
the new Resident driver's license
transfer requirements specifying when a
Division of Motor Vehicles shall send
violation notices and appropriating
funds to the division for technological
upgrades required for legal compliance
chair recognized as representative
Gorski for a motion thank you Mr chair I
vote for a motion for OTP on 133 motions
ought to pass is there a
second seconded by representative hlin
care to speak to your motion sir yes
thank you um this bill is is going to
help in terms of making sure that uh
license requirements are being met in
terms of being registered to vote uh we
had uh
testimony from secretary um David
scanlin who supports the bill and
supports the language of the bill and
based on all that I think it's a worthy
bill that we should pass so that's why I
vote
OTP anybody else from the
committee I saw representative
sees thank you um so I would have to be
opposed to the ought to pass motion um
uh it my opposition is fundamentally
related to uh several factors but the
first one I want to talk about is that
there's the cost so there is no money
according to the fiscal note
um it says quote unquote this bill does
not provide funding nor does it
authorize new positions but within the
within the um estimated State impact
there's a $40,000 technology upgrade
cost there's a
$677,000 for DMV position for fiscal
year
2026 70,000 for 2027 and 72,000 for
fiscal year 2028 none of this none of
those none of the funds have been
appropriated for that so the question
has to be just like your home budget all
right you've now going to incur a bunch
of new expenses
what are we going to take away in order
to be able to pay for these things if
this is the work that's required so
that's my first and
biggest uh concern about this bill
secondly um while the the DMV to their
credit did provide us with a with uh
lots of information about the costs we
did not hear that there were any costs
particularly associated with the uh
secretary State's office and I'll take
that at face value but I I never knew a
government agency that could do much
without having some cost and I sort of
wish that they had provided that
information to us so we're sort of
buying
into no cost associated with this um so
for those two reasons primarily um I'm
I'm very concerned that this is given
the fiscal restraints that we face in
the coming bium that this is not the
time for us to be spending money on a
system that
isn't that that is going to cost this
kind of
money anybody else from the committee
representative Miller thank you Mr
chairman uh in addition to some of the
points representative Sykes raised uh
and the cost side of things uh Printing
and postage is also going to become part
of that which does not seem to be
accounted for um but more broadly than
that uh to the point of this is
necessary to ensure uh voting be
appropriate as a moderator also in my
town um I strongly disagree with that we
accept out ofate IDs it is something
that has happened for years it's fine
the people change there's no enforcement
on this there's no indication of what
these these letters do this seems to be
a bill uh that is much more postering
than actual value to our state and our
constituents and I strongly urge folks
to vote against it
anybody else from the
committee really I'm surprised uh I will
chime in on this one just briefly uh
first of all this is a exact Bill well
not exact it is a very similar Bill to
the one we saw last year and I will
commend the prime sponsor for actually
doing the due diligence reaching out to
and working with to a great extent the
department of M of vehicles and the
Secretary of State both who see now the
Merit in this um you may not necessarily
see it yourself there may not be a
complete uh silver but or golden egg I
guess if you will on what they can do
when when people are in violation of
this now that's the wrong wrong metaphor
but you know what I'm
saying um in other words I see what
they're trying to hear information
sometimes is all you need to be
successful in terms of the the the
funding which I don't disagree with
representative sites um yeah 40 67 70 72
etc etc um I'm making a decision based
on the policy of this and that's why
this is an early bill and I I will
assume that it's going to a committee
that's going to actually look at the the
spending uh specifically if this moves
forward so so I'll be supporting
it um I don't know you're gonna pick on
me okay then you can have
it you would let me anyways even if I
was even if I was going to pick on you
Mr chairman I know that about you um
actually bringing up the point of the
policy I think is it I want I think it's
important to reemphasize that when we do
state law we should do things because
we're fixing problems that have been
identified and need to be fixed the the
issue is what what we don't want to do
is to do more harm than good when we fix
if we fix one thing and then we break
something else elsewhere that's a real
problem the problem with this
legislation is that I see that it's
potentially breaking another piece I'll
speak specifically to the uh one of a
persons who testified in the public
hearing made note of the fact that many
um older
persons who've had I like to
characterize my peers as we've all had
many birthdays okay and at some point in
our lives we we find that we end up that
we go to an assisted living facil
facility and you often have to go to a
facility that is not exactly in your
neighborhood it might be in another town
it might be in another state It's Not
Unusual for Vermont residents for
instance to end up in the nursing home
in north havil New Hampshire which is of
course a lovely Community but uh it's
north havil New Hampshire and um but
they they end up there they don't have a
driver's license that is in date anymore
they have an out-of-date Vermont
driver's license but they are fully
capable of voting and when they show up
to vote to prove who they are they use
their out ofate Vermont
license under this what is the DMV going
to do they're going to send them a
letter to say that they have to um get a
New Hampshire driver's license it
there's an added cost there for the
state that is unnecessary and and makes
it more a little more challenging for
moderators and for um for the voters and
for that reason I like I said we may be
fixing one problem here but we're
creating another one elsewhere and for
that again I can't I can't support this
bill represent
G thank you Mr chair uh I am going to
support the bill for several reasons and
I'm going to offer a resource that has
also been offered uh to your concern
representative sees so when um the
Secretary of State and the director of
Motor Vehicles come in here and they say
that something is a good idea that
reinforces their job and it helps with a
problem that they have envisioned I'm
inclined to believe them and vote in
that favor also this legislative body
just a couple years ago supported the
funding of the uh we serve you the
Mobile DMV bread truck I don't know if
any of you have ever seen that and the
DMV has that ready to go like if you put
in a request from um a senior home or or
a village such as you know we have a
retirement village in gtown if you put
in a request request through the DMV
they can bring the portable DMV office
and they can do driver's license
appointments out of that portable DMV so
it is a resource that we have to be able
to do that we just need to but use
it not a problem anybody else from the
committee I guess we could go back and
forth on this forever I I don't see the
issue I don't think this breaking
anything else uh nobody's ever in my
time here had a qualm about the fact
that after 60 days it's current law
you're supposed to uh get your license
here uh for whatever reason if you don't
this bill is just shuring up what we
already have in law and by sending out
notifications so those people that
haven't complied with law yet that it's
time to do so I've also believe in the
hearing that I heard that this may be
part one of the bill this is a good
thing to move forward and in terms of
any any enforcement there could be a
part two coming down the road so so for
that I I'll be supporting it once again
anybody from the committee seeing none
motion on the floor is ought to pass and
I will ask the clerk to call the rule
when she
very Vice chairman Gorski yes clerk post
yes representative Hill yes
representative foot yes representative
pataro yes representative Koker yes
representative gas
yes yes representative Hamin yes
representative syes
no representative Sinclair no
representative
Fox no representative v no
representative Johnson no Representative
pondon no representative Miller
no um chairman
Walsh
yes just
N9 to7 favor okay uh our recommendation
about the pass is adopted
97 uh this will be going on the regular
calendar I'm going to close the
executive session on House Bill
um uh will there be a Minority Report oh
yeah okay is it going to be just let me
know
before I we'll figure out who's going to
do it let me know there will be a
Minority Report yes
all right now we're going to go into um
in a few minutes host Bill
258 and actually for people um that are
in the
gallery we have had a couple of changes
uh we've decided with some amendments
that we cannot get done today there'll
be further work to be uh taken up on
House Bill
182 and House Bill
260 so I will not be taking those up
today uh look for the calendar I'll have
those rescheduled
excuse me uh I'm going to open up the
executive session on House Bill
258 establishing a study commission to
determine the Readiness of the New
Hampshire SE Coast emergency evacuation
plan um do I have a
motion see this is what
happens representative Hill I will move
itl there's motion on the floor itl
second by representative gason anybody
would you care to speak to your
motion
briefly
itl
yeah um there were a number of things in
the uh in the bill is filed that needed
work um I'll give you one example it was
suggested that there would be I forget
how many people but a certain number of
people from Massachusetts on on the uh
on the new commission um no indication
of how they're picking those
Massachusetts people or who was going to
pick those Massachusetts people um
number of things like that a member
representing the United States Army Corp
of
Engineers who's going to do that um
representing Department of
Transportation again so um I think there
was an awful lot of work to do more so
than what would have been accomplished
um in in just a study session or an
extra couple weeks we're we've heard
that there may be an amendment coming
but um no one to my knowledge spoke to
leadership of the committee so um that
such a an amendment was coming was
forthcoming so with that reason for all
those Reasons I'm going to suggest
itl anybody else from the committee
all right seeing no further discussion
I'll ask the clerk to call the role when
she's ready the motion on the floor is
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
259 Vice chairman Gorski yes clerk votes
yes representative Hill yes
representative foot yes representative
Peta yes representative Koker yes
representative gon yes representative
Hamlin yes representative Sykes yes
represent restive Sinclair yes
representative
Fox yes representative a yes
representative Johnson yes
representative pondon yes and
representative Miller yes 16 to
zero 258 yes well did I say it wrong too
when you called the vote you said
25 oh I
really yes chairman
Walsh you let him vote today um I'm a
little off today we need to
talk so our our recommendation of
inexpedient to legislators adopted
160 160
160 uh this one can go on consent ladies
and gentlemen do I have a motion for
consent okay it's been seconded no
objection to consent seeing none consent
that is I'll close the executive session
on 258 next up um
give us a minute to reset House Bill 259
all right I'm going to open up the
executive session on House Bill
259 relative to increasing the number of
handicap license plates and placards the
Department of Motor Vehicle shell May
issue to
individuals chair recognizes
representative pataro for a motion thank
you Mr chair I move ought to pass on HB
259 motion is off to pass is there a
second I see representative G uh care so
represent guys in seconds to motion care
to speak to you motion yes thank you um
very briefly um we had had a lot of
great representatives from different
aspects of the uh handicap Community
come in and different advocacy
organizations and so forth and um just
want to summarize that the language of
this bill um eliminates the limit of the
number of plates that a handicap
individual can get this bill's language
does not touch
placards and when we clarify that for
all
concerned uh it is my impression that
all organizations are enthusiastic about
this bill and um you know we we vetted
it but once again I just want to stress
that this removes the any limit on the
number of handicap plates a handicapped
person with a walking disability can
get anybody else from the committee
thank you sir by the
way
nobody represent of
London I didn't move fast enough just
kidding now thank you Mr just a quick
question in the legisl it's for each
vehicle owned so will the uh individuals
with the handicap be bringing their
registrations in to show that they have
two three four vehicles that they need
placards
for um thank you for the question uh
honestly I'm not 100% sure of the um a
toz of the mechanics of the the process
of how to apply and then receive um
these materials um I can tell you with
the current situation that if you run
into a situation where you have um
spouses who are both handicapped the end
result would be one handicap plate even
if they each stoned an a vehicle and
three placards this bill is a first step
in addressing one aspect of this which
is the limit on plates where it should
be where both spouses no matter how many
cars they have each one of the cars that
they register and drive should have a
handicap
plate but the answer your question
represent and yeah these these are not
cover plates so you're registering the
vehicle with those plates so obviously
you need proof of ownership of the
vehicle you know so it's not like a
vanity plate or I mean a cover plate
that you could put on anything these are
specific to the vehicle anybody else
from the committee represent of SES yeah
I just I just want to be clear actually
if if a married couple have two cars
they can both register those vehicles
under current law and both get a
handicap plate so there is no limitation
as far as that goes um the bill itself
does not address um placards per se and
only talks about plates
um I'm very in all cander I am very
ambivalent about this bill um DMV is was
not I I I'm not trying to put words in
any member of the DMV uh mouth but they
were I
think they were equally ambivalent about
uh not being
particularly uh supportive of this bill
so um I'm I'm inclined to vote against
it because I think it has it raises a
few questions I think the idea that we
would make handicapped
accessibility uh
issues easier for people is a good one
but I'm not sure that this I'm no pun
intended I'm not sure this bill is the
proper vehicle in order to achieve
that representative
G so uh I am I am favoring this bill if
you
have um if you have a circumstance where
somebody has more than one vehicle um
their option is either a license plate
or a placard and right now one of the
chief complaints that we've heard about
anything to do with the placard
situation is that the placards are
easily um gotten offline uh fraudulently
and that they can be hard to track a
license plate is a part of your
vehicle's registration and it is bolted
to the vehicle is much easier to track
it is much harder to defraud and so if
you are a person who has you know
multiple vehicles with one handicap
person you know you have a truck to tow
your trailer and a commuting car or some
any combination you know a vehicle and a
motorcycle then you could get license
plates for either and it would not
influence the defrauding of the
placards um it' be easier to track
easier to hold accountable and it is
tied to the registration of the
vehicle thank you sir anybody else
representative Miller uh thank you uh
building on that thought of the fraud
there I'm curious me this doesn't remove
placards from circulation this doesn't
change any of that how is this reducing
fraud as opposed to arguably making it
easier for if there is a family with
multiple people or with multiple
vehicles and one handicapped person
arguably this makes it easier for that
fraud to happen when someone drives the
the an able-bodied person drives the car
in pars hand space anyway because it's
on the license plate no that was a
questiones go ahead
represent so um to your point on the
placards uh I do think you know I don't
have a crystal ball but I do think
there's a reckoning coming where all of
placards are going to be called into
question because of how easy they are to
defraud um to your question of uh
whether or not somebody could
fraudulently take a a vehicle with
somebody else's license plate and abuse
it I mean it is my sincere belief that
people tend to be decent human beings
and that they don't like when I don't
need my handicap placard I park
somewhere else and I walk in if I'm
having a bad Mobility day then I use a
handicap parking space of ones available
um I believe that most of the populace
is like that and I also don't think that
we can um I don't think we can legislate
morality and stop fraud in all of its
places but I do think that there's going
to be a reckoning coming with those blue
placards at some point sooner than
later anybody
else we'll leave it at that motion on
the floor is ought to pass uh I'll ask
the clerk to call the rule when she's
ready Vice chairman gski yes clerk votes
yes representative Hill yes
representative foot yes representative
poo yes representative Coker yes
representative gon yes representative
Hamlin yes representative Sykes no
representative Sinclair yes
representative
Fox no representative a
yes representative Johnson
yes representative Pon no and
representative Miller
yes um chairman
Walsh uh
yes 13 to
three okay our uh committee
recommendation our recommendation is uh
of a to pass is adopted 133 leave that
one on regular calendar I'm going to
close the executive session on House
Bill
259 uh next up we'll keep going in order
for now House Bill 287 give us a few
minutes to reset thank
you e
okay I'm going to open up the executive
session of
on where am I House Bill 287 requiring
police departments to provide fire
departments with certain motor personnel
and insurance
information following a motor vehicle
incident um chair recognizes
representative Hill for a motion thank
you Mr chairman uh I would move itl on
House Bill
287 motion is inexpedient to legislate
is there a second second seconded by
representative foot K to speak to your
motion sir
um sure um we were told after the
hearing um nothing arrived during the
hearing unfortunately but we were told
after the hearing that uh there is a
federal hipple law that uh does not
include fire departments as uh approved
on the list of whom the police may share
victim information with
um so it appears that police do have U
some authority to share information but
only under certain circumstances or
situations um as as if when a potential
danger to the victim's health or safety
but only the necessary information
should be shared to address the
immediate emergency and still comply
with privacy laws so it seems that there
are some police departments that are
able to circumvent these laws when
it's when it's uh a a high cost item
that fire department needs to re recover
for but um in general just asking for
their name and address um to to get
information for their insurance company
for things like Speedy dry is um is a
violation of Hippo laws so uh with that
re uh as my basis I am uh suggesting we
vote itl on this
thank you sir anybody else from the
committee oh
representative um I'm running a blank
I've only said it 16 16 times today
Miller it's Miller time
um wow that landed way better than I
expected thank you
all um Can can you clarify where that
hip information came from that does not
align with what my understanding is of
the law in particular how it applies to
law enforcement and so the fact that it
came in here late and not during the uh
hearing is a little concerning to me
no may
follow I um are you scrambled here uh
actually yeah how conf are you that the
longer story um was uh after we had the
hearing um several of us had to go to a
uh a Chairman's uh function and uh and a
lobbyist grabbed my arm and said I have
some information about that bill you
heard today and um and he was the one
that um that said uh federal laws aren't
going to allow you to get that
information I've asked at the time I
gave him my business card and said um
send me that federal law I'd like to
know more about it um so even right up
until now um actually um it turns out
Small World New Hampshire is that um
representative foot is uh familiar with
this person that uh that had this uh
information for us I went looking and
and
scrambled they talk unfortunately a lot
in on the internet and when I was
looking for the information about the
reverse um when fire departments are
able to give information to police
departments but there's not much
information of when police can give
information to fire departments um but I
did uh I did find that line and and you
can tell that I read it um from this
that was saying in certain circum
certain situations such as when
potential danger to the victim's health
or safety but only necessary information
should be shared so um that's that's my
reasoning I don't you know I'm not a
hippo attorney and I'm not uh um as you
can tell well versed on HIPPA laws so if
I one more yeah very briefly um my
understanding is that Hippa only applies
to healthc care providers which the fire
depart the excuse me the police
department would not be a health
provider in that sense that the Privacy
situation for the health provider would
not apply yeah I well I I am also not an
expert but that's my understanding so if
that's if that's the reason we're gonna
itl this I think we might want to
consider a different path that we could
actually get an answer that we can
confirm rather than guessing so what
that is only go by the information in
front of me um and it was um there's a
whole host of people that can't share
information like District Attorneys and
police have discretion to share
information they possess so it's not
just limited to uh to Medical people um
other than that um I don't disagree with
the idea of um nailing it down but for
my purposes at this point um uh
calling it inexpedient to legislate I
think it's it seems that I've hear I've
heard it from two sources now so I'm
comfortable with my own
vote representative
a thank you Mr chairman um it's my
understanding that Hippa applies to
privileged medical information if you're
just exchanging motor vehicle insurance
policy numbers with so they can charge
back to the insurance company rather
than having to charge directly to the
victim so they have to go back to their
insurance company for reimbursement
later that doesn't apply to this um it's
not MediCal it's not it doesn't fall
under Hipp at all this would be under
Fire and safety under state
laws reading thank you oh yep
um it's really hard not taking your mind
out of the chair position you know um so
uh as I'm reading here um and I'll Grant
you this is late information but um it
appears that it's more privacy than it
is um medical limited to Medical so uh I
believe what the what the the bill was
calling for or looking for was
information for for insurance companies
for billing purposes for
um he mentioned Speedy dryer somebody
did um so I think that's where they're
where the Police Department um as it
happens in my community is relying on I
think they're they're talking about U
they're not releasing Privacy
Information and they're deeming um
contact information and um in that list
of
things representative s thank you Mr
chairman so um couple of things at first
blush one just to talk a little bit more
about this Hippa thing um at first blush
one would not think that the American
Red Cross would be um privy to any
health information about persons but
they in fact can they are an exception
to hipper they are allowed to obtain
this information and and use it as
necessary so I I think the the my
concern is that there's if we're going
to not pass a bill we should do so based
on the fundamentals of the bill and I'm
not sure that this uh Hipp argument is
there the other thing that I noticed was
information obtained by the law
enforcement agency that accident
participants are required to exchange
pursuant to the RSA 264 colon 25 to an
owner operator or passenger of a vehicle
involved with said accident this is the
kind of information that people exchange
all the time with just regular people
not necessarily just the police and so
um I I think privacy concerns are
overstated in terms of uh fire
departments wanting to be able to uh
obtain the necessary information to bill
for their services which they are
allowed to do under
rsas um they're allowed to bill for
health related issues with as far as the
ambulance is concerned they're also if
there's a Hazmat material uh incident
they're allowed to build the owner of
the property who caused the Hazmat
incident in the first place they are
allowed to bill for these types of
things so what what
they it is
unfortunate that some police departments
don't fail do do not always feel that
they can or should provide this
information I think this would provide
Clarity so that um the information can
be exchanged in in an appropriate
fashion under this bill um I I I look at
this and say no harm no foul I mean
we're not it isn't causing any harm for
the police departments to share
information that they that people are
required to exchange anyways and why
wouldn't we help our
citizens recover cost
that their fire department takes on on
their behalf so that they don't have to
continue to pay for these things out of
budget um and it this could be pennies
it could be dollars it could be tens of
thousands of dollars and um I think we
have an obligation to our citizens to
help um in this regard
anybody else in the
committee yes is yeah
um go have representative Johnson I'm in
the I'm in the middle of reading
26425 actually go ahead thank you Mr
chairman my question is for
representative Hill after you had this
conversation with the lobbyists did you
have a subsequent conversation with the
primary sponsor of the bill and if
so what what can you tell us no
thank
you anybody else representative
Gorski thank you Mr
chairman the the issue with this bill
for me is we're trying to legislate
conversation and to me I'm not a big fan
of making a law to legislate
conversation between two departments
these departments should be able to kind
of work this out I have a problem trying
to legislatively build a law to say you
two must talk so this is where I have a
problem with this bill and that's why I
can't support
it you know representative Gorski
dropped the mic because actually I as I
read through
26425 representative Sykes is right too
yeah this is normal information that's
shared in an
accident if they everybody was getting
along we wouldn't be sitting here for
the last half an hour and you're right
this bill is just a a way to make people
get along why they're not giving the
information when it's requested of them
I don't know I don't know how we're
going to fix it even with this passing
uh anybody else from the committee
representative G thank you Mr chair um I
was just looking federally in this law
becomes redundant because the code of
administration enforcement already has a
law on inter agency cooperation that was
uh that was re get gets renewed by FEMA
at a minimum every two years most recent
amendment to it was 2022
what's
up I go ahead one more time with that
there's a federal law in place already
that tells agencies that they must have
inter agency cooperation and
communication and it is overseen by the
Federal Emergency Management
agency so that's more evidence in your
opinion that this is not needed at state
level yes sir represent of sees thank
you for that information so the the
issue is that
how if police departments are not
sharing the
information most small volunteer fire
departments will a probably not be aware
of this and B even if they were aware of
it then what this is a very clear-cut
example where we can intervene on the
part of the small towns and fire
departments in order to help their
operations and I I just I that's for me
that's the bottom
line represent SES you even if this
passes I agree with your question even
if they do not provide the information
then what because I believe it was even
the prime sponsor at the hearing that
said maybe we should do more about some
kind of penalty or punishment if they
don't comply
so I'll tell you I never would have
thought in a million years when I walked
in here this morning that this is the
bill that we were going to be spending
an hour
on anybody else from the
committee oh representative
Hill well I wanted to suggest that
perhaps um we recess this to next
executive session and in the meantime we
ask our very capable researcher to see
if we would be overstepping Federal
bounds to um do as representative syy
suggests and make it easier for our
local fire departments um which I don't
think we're capable of doing um but it
would be helpful if we
knew they either are federally allowed
to be on this list or ferally not
allowed on this list just a suggestion
sorry about
that well it's true and seeing as how we
have had a a spirited debate on this for
a better part of an hour and we do have
a couple of questions and it is also our
first day of executive
sessions I'm not opposed to doing that
so I will recess this till the next day
of executive session which will be and I
will reschedule it too publicly but just
for everybody that's here I we will
reschedule this for the is at the 3 is
that our next Tuesday I
believe I don't know looking at a
calendar four fourth so I I will add
this to the schedule for a next
executive sessions on February 4th so
with that as we recess
298 I no 287
right
e
e e
all right so
okay we get a little change in plans
here um I'm going to open up we're move
going to move ahead um we're going to
open up the executive session on on
House Bill 326
FN prohibiting the operation of antique
passenger vehicles model year 1968 rer
on state or local highways for more than
20 miles unless the vehicle is fitted or
retrofitted with seat belt or safety
belts sh recognizes representative guing
for a motion I mooving expedient to
legislate don't I'll jump at once who
second in that representative foot okay
so it's moved and second it inexpedient
to legislate care to speak your motion
sir yes sir thank you Mr chair
so this bill creates a a plethora of
issues uh one of the first ones is is
Law Enforcement issue by restricting a a
vehicle to 20 miles on public roadways
or as it's written um state and local
highways you're creating a circumstance
where uh where the police have to act
with prejudice and Target antique
vehicles and then going on a fishing
expedition to ask them how far they've
driven that day it doesn't say 20 mil
per day it says 20 miles it doesn't say
20 miles per sitting it says 20 miles so
you could ride 18 miles get out and do
something ride another 18 miles um so
from an enforcement aspect this is
nearly impossible also from an
enforcement aspect neighboring laws that
have uh or neighboring states that have
laws that protect collectors do not have
laws similar to this which means that if
somebody from out of state came into the
state 20 miles after they cross the
border they are actually committing a
crime against the state of New Hampshire
uh further people that collect Vehicles
like this will lose a lot of value um
and by talking to many collectors and by
doing nada research and Kelly BL value
research uh it comes into between uh 30%
and 50% in value loss the minute you put
an uh an a modification on an antique
vehicle that cannot be undone and in
many of these cases in order to mount
restraint systems in you would have to
either replace the frame or weld
additions onto the frame and that
assumes that it's a metal frame vehicle
and not a wooden frame vehicle which
anything be bor born before about 19 28
could possibly be so you're creating a
detriment to the investor of the
property you're creating a traffic uh a
traffic non-compliance issue and
enforceability um so for those reasons I
stand in expedient to
legislate thank you sir anybody else
from the
committee um yep rips and a foot thank
you Mr chairman and basically in short
uh we are a state with no mandatory seat
belt lost unless you're under a certain
age um and I just think this bill is
uh
um I can't think of the word but anyways
it's can't yes it's yeah I was trying to
be the wrong way um yeah it's just it's
just unenforceable and it's it it has no
pertinent
value very good uh thank you sir yeah
I yeah there's no need for me me a chime
in on this I completely agree um I will
ask the clerk to call the role when
she's ready the motion on the floor
isn't expedient to
legislate Vice chairman gors yes clerk
votes yes representative Hill yes
representative foot yes representative
poo yes representative Coker yes
representative gon yes representative
Hamlin yes representative
Sykes yes representative Sinclair yes
representative Fox yes represent a yes
representative Johnson yes
representative London yes representative
Miller yes and chairman Walsh yes 16 to
zero consent
consent okay um 16 still here yeah uh
our recommendation of inexpedient to
legislate is adopted 160 I heard a
motion for consent and it was seconded
okay without objection consent is it is
I'll close the executive section on 326
um so it's we're actually doing okay
even though it doesn't always look it um
we're going to take a break for a few
minutes we just got a fresh Amendment
for 140 I'd like the members to have an
opportunity to
review and there is the
potential for some further work on a
couple of
others and it's time to stretch from
minute anyway so give us a it is 10 of
now actually that's probably not right
it's
252 wow somebody changed the clocks um
what do we do this
uh we will go back in we'll take a break
until
310 thank you
second
e
e e
all right I believe yeah we're we're in
time um okay I'm going to open up the
executive session on House Bill 140 FN
establishing a voluntary blue envelope
program for drivers with autism spectrum
disorders uh chair recognizes
representative gon for a
motion I move to
OTP HB 140 FN okay so we have a motion
about to pass on 140 do I have a second
second second by representative Hill uh
the bill is open for further Amendment
uh chair recognizes representative gas
to introduce an
amendment thank you Mr chair actually
but not to interrupt you but if you can
just at the top left side you'll see the
number if you can just introduce it
using the number that's
there 2025 oh oh thank you yep just for
the record all right thank you Mr chair
I am introducing Amendment uh
2025-the includes what we used to know
as PTSD or pts uh the reason and this uh
when I when I asked about recommending
this amendment the sponsors agreed the
reason is
because am I doing something wrong no I
am okay I just need to get a second on
the amendment second representative
Coker did you get a second amendment on
the I got the second I got a second on
the motion yes yeah I didn't get a
second on the amendment and I apologize
all
yours thank you Mr
chair so it it adds in addition to
autism spectrum uh trauma and stress
related disorder much the same way um
persons with autism spectrum uh
disabilities can have escalated
Encounters of somebody doesn't know
their triggers and know how to uh
interact with them in order to
deescalate uh persons with stress
Related Disorders have many of the same
symptoms in terms of uh the tendency to
escalate if they're not handled in in a
favorable Manner and rather than adding
more envelop envelopes and other
problems after discussing this with the
bill sponsors uh it was agreed that this
would be a good tack on so that it could
cover all persons who may have uh have
issues with escalation in what would
otherwise be a routine traffic
stop thank you sir any questions on the
amendment offand from your conversations
um would would this language also
incover uh TBI uh traumatic brain
injury so to your question um a stress
related disorder is not necessarily in
line with a traumatic brain injury but
often they are and most of the time
somebody with a traumatic brain injury
is treated for a stress related disorder
in addition to TBI excellent thank you
anything else or anybody else on the
amendment itself represent Stakes yeah
I'd like to uh speak in support of the
amendment um I think it's a really good
step for us to take um and I do so for I
I will actually share with everybody for
personal reasons um those of you who
know me well know that I ended up being
deployed to the country of Haiti right
after the earthquake for the
International Federation of the Red
Cross red crescent um it was two years
of people shooting at me not personally
of course but people shooting at me um
no family support system dead bodies in
the street uh Starving Children and when
I came back from that I was a absolute
wreck thank goodness I had a spouse who
was willing to put up with me and I know
you're going to all laugh at this but
actually um a big part of the Salvation
was that someone asked me to run for the
legislature so I had something to do
that seemed worthwhile that
wasn't um bringing back the bad memories
of of all that work so I think this is a
really good thing to do because it's a
it is
a if you haven't walked in those shoes
it's a really really hard thing for
people to understand and this will help
with
understanding anybody else from the
committee on the
amendment okay seeing none I just want
to check on one thing
okay so I just wanted to confirm it's
always been and it still is I just
wanted to make sure on an amendment for
those of you who are new and we don't
not have to roll call it unless we think
it's going to be contentious we can
always roll call it in this case I'm
going to say we're probably okay with a
Voice vote so on
Amendment uh
0129 H all those in favor say I I oppose
nay okay so we'll consider that
unanimous adoption of the amendment uh
now the motion on the floor is ought to
pass as amended on House Bill 140 uh any
further discussion on the amended Bill
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the role again it's sought to pass as
amended uh whenever she has a
chance Vice chairman Gorski yes clerk
votes yes representative Hill yes
representative foot yes representative
POA yes representative Coker yes
representative gon yes representative
Hamlin yes representative
Sykes yes representative Sinclair yes
representative Fox yes representative ve
yes representative Johnson yes
representative lundon yes representative
Miller yes and chairman Walsh yes 16 to
zero
was a very small fiscal note
too remember
10,000,000 could consent what we'll do
is the same what we'll do is the same
thing before okay our recommendation of
all to passes amended is adopted 160
unanimous uh I did hear a motion for
consent what's that consent uh and so is
SE so without objection I believe this
meets threshold to go on consent
uh if it doesn't it won't be there and
if you don't if it's not that's why uh
but I think I'm but the
consious what's that do you want it on
consent or you I would I would like it
on
consent well there's um an option I
guess I mean I
heard a motion for consent and a second
I think
would you like to speak to it put it on
regular calendar and speak to it I would
I okay I would I think I think that my
message is an important one I the other
thing that this is actually really hard
for me even just now just to talk about
this um the other thing is that when you
when you are suffering that
way you you don't even recognize that
that's what's going on and when somebody
throws you a
lifeline and this is in my mind a
Lifeline that people can carry with them
that will help um it's so important so
important and I would be happy to
educate the floor of the house about why
this is why this is an important
addition to a program that will help
people fair enough so uh what we can do
we'll we'll put it on the regular
calendar that's easy um and I'll have
the two of you work on whether it's uh
the the speech itself or the the
Parliamentary inquiry so we'll work
together on that okay um so in summary
regular calend letter is ought to pass
this amendment on on 140 I'll close the
executive
session
so let me see here
as I said earlier 182 we're going to
further work 260 same
thing 298
all right so we're going to add House
Bill 298 to the ones uh
I again was not here last week and I do
apologize but uh in looking at it again
today I think it needs some more work I
couldn't support it the way it is so
we're going to push that one off I'll
reschedule that one for next week as
well but this is um again it's our only
our first um executive session this term
and it's a good opportunity to show with
some of the ones that we've been waiting
for amendments when we go through these
bills in the hearings from here on and
if you see one that takes where you've
got concerns with at any time you want
to suggest or recommend uh whether it's
a subcommittee reach out to me we can
put a put two or three people together
well three for a subcommittee uh or if
you think that's something that you've
got an issue with in a bill don't
hesitate to get moving on an amendment
and I can help you through that process
as well if you haven't done it yet
that way when we get to our executive
sessions once they're scheduled we've
got the information we need rather than
rescheduling and rescheduling and
rescheduling so uh again it's all good
we're just getting our our feet wet this
year and off we go we got seven out of
10 done today not too bad uh I will be
putting or we Ted and I represent Gorski
and I will be putting a schedule
together for next Tuesday um and we'll
get into a routine you'll see we'll try
to do hearings in the morning maybe
sneak a couple more in the afternoon and
start ex executing the bills behind us
to fill up and and balance off the days
so anything from the for the good of the
committee from
anybody seeing none thank you very much
and uh we'll see you next
Tuesday
e for